donc aujourd'hui nous allons
pour parler euh du climat
qui connaît le visage d'un gentleman sur le
juste là
Pas plus
non oui 10 15
des gens qui savent ce qu'il faisait à
le temps
ouais ouais donc
très bien et il s'appelle
exactement ancien premier ministre de la france
so mr laurent fabius en décembre 2015
frappe comme un commissaire-priseur son marteau sur
le bureau et déclare
accepté ou approuvé les accords de paris
qui dit que les pays du
planète
feront de leur mieux pour s'assurer que
la hausse de température reste bien inférieure à 2
degré Celsius
donc si cet accord était effectivement ou
avait plutôt une portée pratique effective
je pourrais remplacer cette classe par un grand
la récréation vous disant que le problème est
résolu
et ça ne vaudrait pas la peine de te déranger
expliquer pourquoi
quand ce qui se passe avec ses problèmes c'est
attendu donc malheureusement
ça prendra encore deux heures et demie
pour vous expliquer que le problème est
très très loin d'être résolu et que
il reste encore un peu de distance
entre la tasse et les lèvres
ici vous avez une courbe de l'atmospherique
concentration de co2 exprimée en
millions de sorte que nous exprimons l'atmosphère
concentration de co2 en général
et je vais revenir longuement
qu'est-ce que le co2 et d'où il vient, etc.
mais qui s'exprime en partie par volume
C'est
la fraction molaire de l'atmosphère
exprimé en volume
qui est composé de co2
ce sont des millions donc vous avez sur ce
graphique
300 ppm ou 300 millions c'est 0,03
c'est aussi comme ça que tu peux le voir
et au lieu d'être diplômé selon
années par exemple cette année est
correspond à 1995 et cette année
correspond à 2017.
j'ai obtenu mon diplôme en fonction du nombre de
la réunion annuelle de la conférence des
les parties à la convention climat
tu connais la convention sur le climat je vais
revenez bientôt pendant ce cours dans le
le prochain
c'est l'accord de l'u.n que tous les
pays de la planète ont signé et
alors
ratifié qui disait que nous allions
prendre soin de toi c'est sauver le
générations futures
depuis sa signature en 1992 et je pense
qu'en 1992 il n'y avait pas grand monde
dans cette chambre qui sont déjà nés
donc les générations futures c'est toi et dans
ce document, nous avons dit que nous allions prendre
soin de l'avenir
générations et pour qu'il soit signé en
1992 puis ratifiée en 1995
donc en 1995 c'était euh un grand succès
depuis la convention climat qui dit
on va s'occuper de toi
vient en premier et il y a le premier
réunion annuelle de la conférence des
parties donc ce que nous appelons la conférence
des parties ce n'est pas un tas de
bouchers qui se réunissent et discutent
quelles sont les bonnes coupes de boeuf maintenant
la conférence des parties c'est le
assemblée annuelle des parties à la
convention parce que dans le jargon de l'u.n
un pays qui signe ou ratifie la
la convention s'appelle une fête qui est juste
comment c'est
et donc les parties ont les conventions
sont les pays ou les entités
parce que l'union européenne a certifié
qui ont ratifié la convention
donc tu es l'une des vies de ça
convention qui entre en vigueur en
95 grand succès évidemment 97 est le
année du protocole de kyoto qui est et
je ne reviendrai sur aucun détail mais
lequel est
une annexe d'une convention sur le climat en
dont nous disons bien qu'il y a un certain nombre de
pays du monde qui vont
prendre
engagements de réduction quantitative
y compris la france donc la france dit le
les émissions provenant de ma terre vont baisser
de cinq pour cent entre
telle ou telle année et bien d'autres
pays ont pris exactement la même
type d'engagements afin que vous voyiez le
effet qu'il a eu sur l'atmosphère
chevron de concentration
peut-être Copenhague décrit comme un immense
échec
bien gommer paris décrit comme un énorme
Succès
on verra donc cette petite introduction est
là pour vous montrer que malheureusement et
nous verrons
un certain nombre d'autres événements que je vais montrer
toi plus tard
jusqu'à maintenant la quantité de bruit faite
le changement climatique est un paramètre qui a
aucune influence sur ce qui est vraiment
ça se passe bien donc il y a deux
processus décorés dans le monde qui
sont ce qui se passe vraiment
en termes d'émissions et résultant
processus climatiques et
le nombre de personnes qui ont dit ça
quelque chose devrait être fait
d'accord ce sont deux processus qui
sont pour un moment totalement distincts
malheureusement nous allons parler de
changement climatique
et en parlant de climat je le ferais
insistez même pour les bons cerveaux que vous
sommes
dont nous allons parler
quelque chose qui est inaccessible à votre
sens
d'accord, tu es peut-être très brillant
élèves-ingénieurs
sélectionné pour entrer dans un très difficile à
accéder à l'école tu restes des animaux comme moi
et donc tu fais confiance à tes sens
parce que l'espèce humaine est une espèce
qui fait confiance
ses sens donc on date d'une époque où
nos sens
nous a dit que nous devions échapper au
tigre à dents de sabre qui
Je n'ai pensé qu'à faire de nous une collation
et donc nous sommes
nous savons les choses que nos sens donnent
nous dans notre immédiat
l'environnement en ce qui concerne le climat
paramètres ce que nos sens peuvent
indiquer dans notre environnement immédiat est
la température immédiate où nous sommes
éventuellement les précipitations immédiatement
où nous sommes
la luminosité immédiatement où nous sommes
la nébulosité qui doit sauver
nuages ​​immédiatement
où nous sommes les vents immédiatement où
nous sommes etc.
ces paramètres appréciés localement et
instantanément
dans la science qui mène à ce qu'on appelle
la météo
donc le temps est l'instantané et
évolution locale ou dans un futur très proche
des choses qui parlent à nos sens qui
sont les conditions qui seront
ici ce matin pour savoir si j'allais
mettre un manteau ou pas j'ai regardé le
le temps qu'il allait faire à paris
et je m'en fous à un degré élevé de
faire quel temps il fait aujourd'hui
buenos aires mais mon manteau
ça m'intéresse pas tout ça
m'intéresse c'est de mettre mon manteau ou pas
c'est si mais ça va être à paris
donc le climat au contraire
dont nous allons parler maintenant est
quelque chose qui est inaccessible à votre
sens
du moins pas de manière directe, c'est dans un
voie directe mais est inaccessible en direct
façon parce que quand on parle de climat
on parle de moyennes
et une moyenne tu le sais comme moi est une
construction intellectuelle
d'accord c'est une série ou une intégrale
donc c'est quelque chose
que vous n'observez pas dans la nature c'est
une construction intellectuelle une moyenne
maintenant c'est cette construction intellectuelle
qui permettra de comprendre
que nous dérivions ou non
hors de l'ordinaire pour quelque chose qui
est notre environnement habituel
donc vous voyez toujours des manifestations indirectes
des climats du monde qui nous entoure
par exemple dans l'indirect
manifestations il y a de la végétation
évidemment la végétation qu'il y a
au Groenland et il y a
beaucoup de végétation qu'il y a en afrique
et la végétation qu'il y a
autour du bassin méditerranéen ne sont pas
le même parce que le climat n'est pas le
même
donc des manifestations indirectes du climat
tu en vois mais
manifestations directes aiment dire
approchez-vous d'une moyenne avec vos sens
pas gérer
donc il y a confusion
à la fois en général, la confusion se produit
du fait que
dans un cas comme dans l'autre on gère
les mêmes critères
c'est à dire que ce sont les mêmes
variables que nous manipulons
mais dans un cas, nous allons examiner
les valeurs instantanées et locales
et l'autre nous allons regarder le
moyennes spatiales ou temporelles ou les deux
et les variations régulières de ces
moyennes par exemple la saisonnalité
la variation fait partie du climat
vous avez des variations saisonnières qui
concernent les températures ce sont les
latitudes moyennes
qui sont éventuellement concernés par le fait
que leur soleil ce sont les pôles
ou qui concernent le fait qu'il y a
beaucoup de pluie ou peu de pluie ce sont
plutôt la région équatoriale
vous avez donc des variations saisonnières qui
ne sont pas toujours les mêmes selon
où vas-tu
donc je vais prendre un autre coup sur mon
ennemis favoris à savoir
journalistes je vais vous donner un exemple
ici de quelque chose qui s'est passé quelques
il y a des années
de quelque chose qui s'est passé il y a quelques années
il y a que j'ai trouvé
intéressant il y a un moment
un article dans le journal
as vera de temps en temps avec les gens
qui veulent se rendre intéressants
en disant regarde
il ne peut y avoir de réchauffement climatique car
la planète en ce moment ne chauffe pas
Il fait froid
donc il s'avère qu'il y a eu un jour
où par hasard
fait qu'il y avait du négatif
anomalies aiment dire plus cool
températures supérieures à la moyenne dans l'ensemble
tas d'endroits très peuplés
vous voyez un morceau d'Europe une partie de la
états-unis une partie du japon etc
maintenant il s'avère que nous sommes très humains
il y a des industries de la presse et il y a
personnes
pour envoyer des communiqués de presse, il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit regarde où je suis
ici aujourd'hui en ce moment il fait froid
sauf qu'au même moment ni
les pingouins
ni les dauphins au milieu du
atlantic ou tous ces gens pourraient dire
mais tu sais chez nous en ce moment
il fait beaucoup plus chaud que la moyenne
donc en fait si tu es vraiment moyen
avec où il fait plus froid et quand il fait
plus chaud
il n'y a pas de problème la moyenne d'un
toute la surface planétaire est bien au-dessus
ses valeurs de référence d'accord et euh
c'est là donc ça continue du temps
il est temps euh
plus rare de nos jours mais euh il y en a encore
certaines personnes qui jouent ces
sortes de petits jeux c'est assez facile
à nouveau en faisant la confusion entre un
valeur instantanée et une moyenne
ne tient qu'à ça et c'est
encore très facile d'accuser les gens qui sont
peu familier avec le sujet
car ce sont les mêmes paramètres
et parce que notre synthèse ne peut pas nous dire
c'est quoi une moyenne
il y a une autre bizarrerie qui est tout à fait
classique je dois changer l'année tous les
année mais
hé c'est le même principe qui est
très classique quand on s'intéresse
dans ce sujet
qui fait des séries mal interprétées
donc là je pourrais dire que les effets de
ce processus est l'augmentation de
températures
je pourrais aussi dire que c'est la diminution
d'un certain nombre de bateaux pirates parce
en fait les sous-vêtements ont diminué à
en même temps que le nombre de pirate
les navires ont décliné de toute façon
il est très facile de mal interpréter ce qui est
être observé
jusqu'à ce que nous comprenions les processus afin
c'est
il est très facile d'avoir une mauvaise conclusion
le climat est donc géographique
ou plutôt des moyennes spatiales et temporelles
mais en fait ces moyennes sont fixées à
changer en fait le climat de la terre depuis
l'existence de la terre n'a jamais été stable
sur les périodes géologiques
donc la période géologique que vous n'avez pas
se soucient vraiment quand vous êtes un homme ou un
femme parce que tu es cette attente si
tout va bien
est de l'ordre de grandeur d'un
siècle et même si tout va mal
c'est de l'ordre d'une décennie
ne te le souhaite pas
alors que se passe-t-il sur un million d'années
mais la terre a traversé très très
des temps contrastés en termes de
climat par exemple il fut un temps
où il n'y avait pas d'oxygène dans
bonne ambiance
l'atmosphère terrestre était composée
principalement de co2 et de méthane et d'azote
il y a eu des moments où la terre était
probablement presque complètement glacé
la calotte glaciaire couvrait la presque totalité
la terre
il fut un temps où il n'y avait pas
continent de toute façon la terre a traversé
extrêmement
états variés
et si nous regardons les derniers millions
ans c'est-à-dire l'ère quaternaire
il y avait même à cette époque super
les oscillations climatiques qui sont les
glaciation déglaciation donc le climat
n'est pas du tout resté stable
et si l'on regarde des échelles de temps qui sont
d'un million d'années ou moins
on a un premier facteur de forçage qui est
appelé le forçage astronomique
donc le forçage astronomique vient de
le fait que le système solaire
n'est pas un ménage de deux mais un
ménage de 10.
donc la terre est attirée par les grosses planètes
du système solaire
donc on n'est pas dans une ellipse parfaite
régulier d'un temps
quel est celui que vous savez comment
calculer dans une géométrie ou quelque chose
avec juste deux corps on est dans un système
avec 10 corps
donc ça ne marche pas aussi bien ni dans aucun
cas ce n'est pas régulier
il y a donc des variations d'orbites
et j'y reviens juste après
et il peut fausser le système climatique sur
des échelles de temps de l'ordre de
100 000 ans avec des continents ne sont pas
toujours où ils
y a-t-il une dérive comme vous le savez
continents et selon la localisation
d'où un
continent est bien le reflet de
l'ensoleillement est plus ou moins important
par exemple quand vous avez un continent
à l'approche des pôles
vous pouvez avoir une calotte glaciaire permanente qui
apparaissent typiquement groenlandais
et à ce stade, vous créez très
surfaces réfléchissantes beaucoup plus réfléchissantes
dans l'eau de l'océan qui était là avant
l'installation de la glace antarctique
plafonnement au pôle sud des dixièmes de millions
il y a des années donc j'ai lu
30 ici 15 là mais de toute façon l'ordre
la grandeur est la même
a bien refroidi le climat planétaire de
quelques degrés
à cause de la création de ce grand
miroir qui évacue une partie du rayonnement solaire
rayonnement sans qu'il ait le temps de
frapper le sol
après tu as interne
oscillations dans le compartiment fluide
de l'atmosphère notamment les processus qui
sont liés à l'océan à grande échelle
circulation
qui peut modifier le climat
des périodes allant de
le siècle au millénaire et
évidemment tu as
la dynamique interne de l'atmosphère
mais cela change le climat
des périodes très très courtes
et puis tu nous as tout en bas
là la cause anthropique
alors sois fier nous sommes devenus un climat
agent nous sommes devenus un agent qui
force le système climatique
quand tu feras la météo je reviendrai
à lui le seul compartiment qui réagit
à l'échelle
de la journée c'est l'ambiance donc tu fais
un bon modèle atmosphérique vous prenez votre
amis bien pas vous parce que vous n'avez pas
savoir comment le faire avec vos amis à
université supérieure ils savent faire
ce
et vous les envoyez à meteo bien sûr et
vous leur demandez de faire un modèle climatique et
ils prédiront correctement quoi que ce soit
d'accord
par contre si tu veux voir comment
le système évolue à l'échelle de la
siècle
ce dont nous allons parler maintenant c'est
pas de quoi faire une bonne ambiance
maquette
cela ne suffit pas il faut
savoir modéliser l'évolution de ces
échelles de temps
d'autres compartiments d'une planète et dans
particulier de l'océan
en particulier de l'océan l'océan est
la
compartiment à fluide qui entraîne le
évolution d'un climat sur le siècle
échelle
bien plus que l'ambiance donc si vous
vous voulez faire un bon modèle météorologique
voir
et si vous voulez faire un bon
modèle climatique sur le pays que vous regardez
vers le bas
à des échelles de temps encore plus longues comme je l'ai dit
sont les paramètres astronomiques qui
dominer
donc ces paramètres astronomiques de l'eau
variantes
d'abord à cause de l'attrait
des grandes planètes du système solaire
vous avez trois paramètres qui vont
varier dans le temps
la première est qu'ainsi la terre ne
faire un glissement exact puisqu'il se déforme mais
c'est une quasi-ellipse dont l'excentricité
est plus ou moins grand
avec une quasi périodicité de 100 000
années
c'est une première variante qui est
introduite par l'attrait de la
grandes planètes la deuxième variation qui
est introduit par les grandes planètes
c'est que tu as l'axe de rotation
de la terre qui est plus ou moins
incliné sur le plan de l'orbite
vous comprenez que si l'axe de
la rotation de la terre était totalement
perpendiculaire au plan de l'orbite
bien aurions-nous des saisons
non nous n'aurions pas toutes les saisons
juste parce que l'inclinaison solaire
serait toujours le même
toute l'année et donc le montant
de chaleur récupérée à une latitude donnée
serait le même toute l'année
et d'ailleurs le climat vient du
mot grec clima
k-l-i-m-a qui signifie inclinaison
d'autre part quand vous avez un
inclinaison extrêmement prononcée bien
selon la période de l'année où vous êtes
vous avez la tête chaude ou les fesses froides
ou vice versa
et vous avez donc un très grand
contraste entre les saisons
d'accord donc plus l'axe est incliné
arrive au plan de l'orbite
en fait, plus il se rapproche de l'avion
de l'orbite disons
plus vous avez un fort contraste
entre les saisons
en particulier à ce moment-là vous avez
des étés plus chauds
et euh des hivers plus froids à mesure que vous vous rapprochez
aux latitudes moyennes
et enfin la dernière chose qui arrive
c'est que tu as
l'axe comme une toupie l'axe de
rotation de la terre qui tourne autour
la perpendiculaire
du plan de l'orbite ce qui signifie
ce
puisque tu as un périhélie et un théon
eh bien vous montrez alternativement la tête de
les fesses c'est le nord
hémisphère ou l'hémisphère sud
au plus proche ou au plus éloigné de
le soleil à droite
donc avec une quasi périodicité de vingt
mille ans
vous avez l'hémisphère nord inversé
lorsque vous êtes
le plus proche du soleil qui regarde
soleil ou partout où le
hémisphère sud d'accord soit un ou
L'autre
et ça change avec un
quasi-périodicité de 20 000 ans
quand tu mets tout ensemble tu as
notamment quelque chose qui varie beaucoup
c'est l'isolation à 65 degrés
les nerfs pour que tu puisses me dire l'isolation
est de 65 degrés ni
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'intéresse tout à coup à ça
alors pourquoi parce que c'est
la zone très sensible qui conditionne
l'entrée en glaciation
ou sortie de glaciation au cours de la
ère quaternaire
parce que c'est un endroit où avec le
variations de ces
paramètres astronomiques, vous pouvez avoir un
très grande variation de
isolation reçue spécialement
en été plus
l'axe se redresse moins le contraste
il y a entre les saisons
et donc à cette époque l'été est
proportionnellement moins chaud
l'été est proportionnellement moins chaud
et quand vous êtes assez proche de la
pouls qu'il neige encore en hiver
à ce moment vous avez la neige qui
ne veut pas trop fondre en été
et la neige commence à s'accumuler année après
année et vous entrez dans la glaciation
d'accord donc en fait l'un des
conditions d'entrée en glaciation
est le fait que l'axe se redresse sur
le plan de l'orbite et corrélativement
quand ça penche c'est l'inverse
tu as un été très chaud et ça commence
fondre donc vous avez ici
les variations d'isolation qui vont avec
les entrées et sorties du dernier
les glaciations
qui sont illustrés ici dans tous ces
paramètres
il y en a un qui est aujourd'hui devenu
le paramètre dominant
désolé je vais devoir m'arrêter 30 secondes pour
trouver une petite animation qui va bien
on y va t'as un peu
animation faite par les seules personnes qui
compter
dans ce monde qui est de sauver le
producteurs champions et le pire c'est
que c'est vrai
ils m'ont fait cette petite animation en
2002 pour une conférence
qui essaie d'expliquer ce que la dynamique
Disons
de l'effet de serre consiste en
qui est l'un des processus
à l'œuvre dans la formation du climat
donc ici vous avez un simplifié
illustration
de la surface de la terre composée de
sols émergés et
océans d'eau et l'apport d'énergie qui
permet à la machine climatique de fonctionner
c'est-à-dire l'énergie solaire depuis la
La machine climatique est comme toutes les machines
le monde, il est soumis à la première loi
de la thermodynamique donc pour elle de faire
quelque chose qui a besoin d'énergie
et que l'énergie est essentiellement apportée
par le rayonnement solaire
donc ce rayonnement solaire quand il arrive
à la surface de l'atmosphère
vous avez essentiellement une fourrure qui est
réfléchie vers l'espace par
tout ce qui est brillant vu de l'espace donc
si vous regardez une photo satellite du
la terre tu as
deux types de surfaces qui sont
particulièrement brillantes qui sont
neige que vous trouverez certainement et
alors
déserts absolument donc vous avez de la neige et
déserts qui sont particulièrement
réfléchissant
ce qui vous draine environ un tiers du
énergie solaire incidente le reste
les deux tiers puisqu'ils ne sont pas reflétés
ou absorbé en particulier absorbé par
le sol
alors le sol comme dans euh
disons comme dans tout système énergétique
obtenir l'énergie qui est que
qu'il absorbe sous forme de lumière
rayonnement ou plutôt
rayonnement électromagnétique pour être plus
précis car disons
50 du rayonnement solaire est infrarouge et
il y a
seulement 40 visibles et 10 ultraviolets
donc le sol absorbe l'énergie solaire
cherchera à se mettre en énergie
équilibrez-le aussi
et le sol a trois façons de
atteindre l'équilibre énergétique mais c'est-à-dire
restaurer
en um en régime stationnaire
l'énergie qui lui est fournie par le soleil
la première façon qu'il a est la chaleur de contact donc
tu es au-dessus d'un sol chaud
vous mettez de l'air dessus la chaleur est
transféré directement par contact c'est
la première façon dont le sol
redonne de l'énergie
une deuxième manière par laquelle le sol restaure
l'énergie donc
ce n'est pas très bien représenté ici mais
vous pouvez encore le voir avec ce petit
chose bleue flashy
c'est la chaleur latente de l'eau
évaporation condensation
donc quand tu chauffes le sol aux deux tiers
dont se trouve être de l'eau
parce que les deux tiers d'une planète sont
couvert de puits d'eau
tu vas évaporer de l'eau et là tu
ont de la chaleur latente qui est utilisée pour le
l'évaporation qui est renvoyée au
atmosphère
et vous aurez un troisième mode d'énergie
revenir
c'est que le sol va rayonner
infrarouge
parce que tu te souviens que n'importe qui au-dessus
zéro kelvin
rayonne donc le soleil dont la surface est à
six mille kelvins
a un spectre dans lequel il y a beaucoup de
rayonnement visible beaucoup de
infrarouge et un peu de terre ultraviolette
qui est en moyenne à 300 kelvins en
ordre de grandeur
bon un peu plus 310 a un spectre
qui est beaucoup plus déplacé vers
longueurs d'onde beaucoup plus importantes
et dans ces longueurs d'onde plus longues, il y a
essentiellement ce qu'on appelle
infrarouge lointain qui est d'ailleurs à peu près
le même rayonnement infrarouge
comme celui que vous émettez qui vous permet de
être vu par une caméra infrarouge ou qui
permet de regarder les rayons infrarouges
s'échappant de la crépine thermique dans
que tu vis
si oui tout ça est dans le même
longueurs d'onde
et il s'avère que l'atmosphère
qui est parfaitement transparent pour
rayons solaires incidents à l'exception des
ce qui ne traverse pas l'atmosphère
ultraviolets oui qui sont interceptés
par une espèce chimique que vous trouvez dans
la stratosphère qui s'appelle l'ozone
bon à part ça
interception
la majeure partie du rayonnement solaire passe
à travers l'atmosphère sans entrave
tandis que le rayonnement réémis par le
planètes et c'est bien
réémis pas réfléchi comme je l'ai parfois
trouver dans vos examens
bon c'est loin
infrarouge pour lequel l'atmosphère sera
contenir
espèces très fortement opaques
pour ces infrarouges et très fortement
opaque
c'est-à-dire qui ont des raies d'absorption
dans
l'infrarouge lointain et en fait le
gaz à effet de serre qui est le
définition c'est un gaz qui a
lignes d'absorption
dans l'infrarouge lointain émis par le
planète
puisque l'ambiance est un travail existant
est essentiellement opaque à ces absorber
l'énergie de son infrarouge puisqu'il
les intercepte
même motif même punition
l'atmosphère cherchera également à atteindre
bilan énergétique
et de se débarrasser de l'énergie qu'il absorbe
quand il est en bilan énergétique
elle n'a qu'un moyen à sa disposition
elle ne peut pas évaporer l'eau ou
tout ce qu'il peut faire est de rayonner
infrarouge
et donc ce qui se passe, c'est que lorsque vous
intercepter l'infrarouge
émis par la surface que vous interceptez
leur
tu les remets et tu vas
les réémettre dans tous les sens
donc une partie va vers l'espace et
finira par mettre la planète
bilan énergétique demandant à l'espace mais
une autre partie retourne au sol et
contribue donc à une deuxième
chauffage du sol
après le chauffage par rayonnement solaire direct
donc en termes de watts par mètre carré
le rayonnement infrarouge du
l'effet de serre est
presque aussi important que le solaire
radiation mais comme je ne me souviens plus qui
dit que t est proportionnel à sigma
fois la température à la puissance quatre
évidemment ça ne double pas le
température d'équilibre du sol
mais ça l'augmente de 30 degrés
celsius donc si une serre naturelle
effet n'existait pas bonne nouvelle pour vous
ce cours n'aurait pas lieu mais mauvais
nouvelles que vous n'existeriez pas
car la terre serait trop loin
du point triple de l'eau pour la vie
avoir lieu au moins pas
la vie telle que nous la connaissons bien donc la
l'effet de serre naturel est un très bon
chose
elle a permis l'émergence de la vie et
d'ailleurs
par une sorte de magie d'équilibrage
processus
l'effet de serre naturel a
a diminué à mesure que l'énergie solaire a
augmenté
car depuis la formation de l'étoile solaire
sa puissance a augmenté
et il y avait une sorte de corrélatif
l'évolution de l'effet de serre et
énergie solaire
ce qui signifie que la température du
la planète ne s'est jamais vraiment éloignée
du point triple de l'eau
en dessous il n'est jamais descendu en dessous du
point triple de l'eau
partout donc le très bon c'est
quelque chose d'assez remarquable
on peut dire que ça marche
à ce stade nous arrivons donc nous arrivons dans le
histoire que je t'ai racontée dans la première leçon
c'est-à-dire qu'on arrive avec notre
Machines
nos vaches et notre seule entreprise et liberté
cinq et sept
huit milliards de bipèdes et ce faisant, nous
vont
initier des activités qui créent
émissions supplémentaires
de gaz à effet de serre en fait de gaz à effet de serre
émissions la planète le fait toute seule
aussi bien
mais nous en ajoutons plus et puisque ces
les gaz à effet de serre ont la mauvaise habitude de
ne voulant pas s'échapper rapidement du
ambiance une fois qu'on les y a mis
je vais bien m'y remettre à ce moment
nous augmenterons l'atmosphère
concentration de gaz à effet de serre donc
nous allons augmenter l'opacité de la
atmosphère au rayonnement infrarouge
émis par la planète
et si on augmente l'opacité du
atmosphère au rayonnement infrarouge
émis par la planète
cela signifie que nous intercepterons même
mieux celles émises par les sols
et de ce fait nous nous réchaufferons même
Suite
la basse atmosphère qui émettra
encore plus
dans toutes les directions y compris vers le
sol donc on va intensifier le chauffage
du sol
donc l'augmentation de l'effet de serre
génère
une augmentation de la surface planétaire
à mesure que nous augmentons le chauffage du sol
alors le sol sera
faire ce qu'il savait faire avec le
rayonnement solaire initial
c'est-à-dire qu'il augmentera chaque
tour
là, il augmentera à chaque terme du
retour d'énergie du sol vers
atmosphère
nous allons donc augmenter la chaleur de contact que nous
augmentera l'évaporation
condensation
et nous augmenterons l'infrarouge
rayonnement émis
et l'augmentera jusqu'à ce que ce soit ce que
parvient à traverser l'atmosphère
ce qu'on appelle la fenêtre atmosphérique
est redevenu identique à ce que nous
avait avant
augmenter les gaz à effet de serre dans
ambiance autrement dit nous reviendrons
au bilan énergétique
vu de l'espace mais en attendant
nous avons intensifié les flux d'énergie
entre le sol et le bas
atmosphère
alors quand tu vois cette petite animation
oui
ils ne les retiennent pas ils absorbent
leur
ils les absorbent et les réémettent c'est
un phénomène d'absorption réémission
les infrarouges qui viennent du soleil ou
courte longueur d'onde infrarouge
nous ne sommes pas les mêmes d'accord c'est ce que nous
appeler le proche infrarouge
l'infrarouge est tout ce qui va au-delà
le visible donc ce n'est pas
euh quelque chose qui est très extrêmement
précis en termes de
de toute façon donc nous sommes habitués à classer
comme proche infrarouge
ceux qui sont proches du visible
spectre dans les mêmes ordres de grandeur
de longueur d'onde
et dans les infrarouges lointains mais ceux qui
sont beaucoup plus loin
ce que vous entendez immédiatement par
regarder cette animation
est que les mouvements convectifs
ou plus exactement des phénomènes extrêmes qui
est originaire
dans les mouvements convectifs fera l'affaire
quelque chose pour ainsi dire
les phénomènes extrêmes qui ont leur
origine dans les mouvements convectifs que vous avez
ouragans donc vous savez qu'un ouragan
commence par un point important
convection avec euh une surface océanique
température qui doit être élevée
de sorte que vous avez beaucoup d'évaporation
tu as des orages
tu as des tornades et tout ça
phénomènes vous comprenez que le moteur
augmentera
parce que la surface chauffe l'évaporation
augmente mais corrélativement à mesure que
part des infrarouges terrestres
sont absorbés près de la surface il y a
moins pour réchauffer la stratosphère
en fait, nous verrons cela dans la prochaine
première classe des marques
de l'effet de serre est que le
la température de surface augmente mais la
la température de la stratosphère diminue
tu augmenteras donc la température
dégradés
de la couche inférieure de l'atmosphère
soi-disant
troposphère les 10 premiers kilomètres et
si vous augmentez
le gradient de température que vous allez
augmenter la puissance convective
donc vous serez forcément à cause de la
traiter
impliqués changer la dynamique de l'extrême
événements
ou phénomènes météorologiques intenses
donc je reviens
à
[Musique]
là donc
une fois que je vous ai expliqué ce que
l'effet de serre est de comprendre ce
arrive
il y a quelque chose que tu dois savoir
c'est-à-dire comprendre le climat
changer sous l'effet de l'homme
Activités
ne résulte pas d'un seul scientifique
la discipline
dans la presse on voit souvent ça et là
le terme climatologue
et donc quand on voit ça on dit à
nous-mêmes climatologue est un
spécialiste de l'évolution climatique
donc en fait des spécialistes du changement climatique
n'existe pas en tant que tel
à aucun moment il n'y a eu de discipline
appelé spécialiste
du changement climatique résultant de l'activité humaine
Activités
ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'au cours de la dernière
30 ans il y a eu
une agence pour agréger les compétences d'un
tout un tas de gens
qui ont été créés sous l'égide de la
Les Nations Unies
qui s'appelle ipcc ou zhiek en français
c'est-à-dire panel international de
changement climatique et en français nous
traduire cela en groupe
qui consiste à demander aux chercheurs de
mettre
ensemble les découvertes de tout un tas
des disciplines scientifiques
donner une vision globale de ce problème
c'est l'évolution du climat sous
l'effet des activités humaines
mais ce n'est pas qu'un seul scientifique
la discipline
donc par exemple je vous ai dit que le
le climat planétaire change
sous l'effet de l'attraction d'un
planète bien vous avez besoin d'astrophysiciens
comprendre la mécanique céleste et
même sans les autres avions d'ailleurs
tu en as besoin
la dynamique atmosphérique, ce ne sont pas les
même vous avez besoin de chimistes atmosphériques ils
ne sont pas les mêmes
vous avez besoin d'ostéographes ils sont toujours
pas le même
etc donc vous avez besoin de tout un tas de euh
et pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont pour
exemple entendu parler d'un homme appelé jean jose
José est mieux placé dans la catégorie des
glaciologues
il a fait sa thèse sur l'isotopie
teneur en oxygène 18 si ma mémoire est
bien
dans les grêlons donc c'est là qu'il est venu
de
alors voilà il te faut tout un tas
de spécialistes
et il a fallu un tour de force du
communauté scientifique
demander à tous ces gens de se parler
autre à donner d'une seule voix
guichet unique d'accès à l'information
appelé le GIEC
une vision de ce qu'était le changement climatique
sous les activités humaines alors pourquoi suis-je
te dire ça
parce que quand tu vas interviewer un
scientifique dans la presse
aucun d'eux n'a à cause de son travail et
dit-il à cause de son travail si vous regardez
à
toutes ces disciplines il peut en avoir une
avec ses lectures
cela ne lui est évidemment pas interdit car
pour toi mais ce n'est pas
son travail qui lui donnera une expertise
du même niveau
sur tout ce qui est mentionné ici
bon alors je stresse
ceci parce que c'est important
savoir que tu n'as plus
climatologues
c'est quelque chose qui n'existe pas donc
parfois nous donnons le euh
le sens le plus proche des climatologues
que nous pouvons trouver la science
communauté
est un modèle le climatologue est celui
qui rend le modèle qui intègre
compétences de tous ses collègues
là au final c'est le moins mauvais
définition
mais c'est quand même quelque chose qui est euh
important
à garder à l'esprit donc
je t'ai dit que je mélange toujours 1824 et
1826 et bien voilà la réponse
donc c'est 1824 la bonne date et
donc 1826
les gaz de schiste dans l'est des états-unis
donc en 1824 la serre
effet a été identifié par joseph
alors notre ami publie un article
dans lequel il dit qu'il y a quelque chose dans
l'atmosphère
ce qui fait que la température du sol est
plus élevé que si
quelque chose n'existait pas donc deux siècles
depuis
presque à quelques années il y a un français
scientifique
frites qui comprend ce terrain
les températures sont
augmentée par le rôle de l'atmosphère
vous avez quelques décennies plus tard un français
encore une fois les irlandais qui s'identifient
les deux principaux gaz à effet de serre que nous
ont dans l'atmosphère qui sont du carbone
dioxyde et vapeur d'eau
donc en fait le fait qu'il y ait un
l'effet de serre en ce qu'il est causé
au premier ordre par la vapeur d'eau et le carbone
le dioxyde est connu depuis plus d'un siècle
il y a et demi
en 1896 un suédois
qui se trouve être puisqu'elle est de votre
génération un des plus grands toonberg
les ancêtres
Je veux dire que la Suède est un petit pays donc ils
peuvent tous être quelqu'un soeur
alors qui se trouve être l'un d'elle
les ancêtres
dans ses temps libres parce qu'il ne pouvait pas
regarder la télé à l'heure
il fait un petit calcul de commandes
d'ampleur sur ce qui se passe si nous
doubler la quantité de dioxyde de carbone dans
l'air
et donc mr ranius dit deux ou trois
des choses absolument fondamentales
il dit un si je double le montant de
co2 dans l'air
la température planétaire augmente sur
moyenne de quatre degrés Celsius
donc en 1896 il y a un premier calcul
d'ordre de grandeur qui tombe sur
bon résultat
il semblerait un peu par chance
et deux et en plus arrhenius
comprend probablement à cause du noir
rayonnement corporel d'ailleurs
que si nous avons une serre supplémentaire
effet
c'est-à-dire une interception supplémentaire
d'infrarouge terrestre dont vous disposez
partout à la surface de la planète
bien le résultat
la température augmente toutes nos choses
être exposé
sera encore plus grand si le démarrage
la température est basse, ce qui signifie que
pour la même puissance rayonnée vers le
sol plus la température de départ
est faible plus la hausse de température est élevée
à cause de la température à la puissance de
quatre dans la formule du corps noir
donc les iraniens ont dit à ce moment-là quelque chose
qui est parfaitement
vrai et qui nous permet aujourd'hui de dire
que c'est bien l'effet de serre
c'est vers l'extérieur
c'est-à-dire qu'il augmentera plus vite à
les pôles
s'il y a plus d'effet de serre
la montée en température sera plus rapide au
pôles que les tropiques qui est
exactement ce qui se passe qu'il va
monter plus vite
la nuit que le jour qui est
se produit également mais il augmentera plus rapidement
en hiver qu'en été qui est aussi
événement
donc les arènes ont compris ces deux choses dans
mais ça
donc tu sais que les anglais sont un peu fous
c'est pourquoi ils sont créatifs ils sont
à la fois conservateur et fou
et donc il y a presque un siècle, il y a un
anglais qui s'imagine faire un digital
simulation
mais à l'époque il n'y avait pas d'ordinateur donc
comme il n'y avait pas d'ordinateur, il a dit que je suis
va prendre des physiciens ou je ne sais pas
tous les ingénieurs de cette université
De toute façon
alors il a dit que je vais comme un orchestre
pour les contrôler tous avec mon bâton
leur faire résoudre les équations dans un
mode unitaire
l'un derrière l'autre évidemment
ne fonctionne pas mais
dès que le premier ordinateur est
développé et
vous verrez certaines de ses caractéristiques
dans l'un des prochains cours bien
certains physiciens sautent dessus pour faire le
première
modèle de simulation du comportement de la
atmosphère
donc l'idée que nous pouvons utiliser le numérique
outils
dire des modèles pour essayer de comprendre quoi
arrivera plus tard
il n'apparaissait pas avec la dernière
version de jeux vidéo
c'est quelque chose qui est très très ancien dans
termes
de la science du climat ainsi
il y a une chose que je n'ai pas montrée
cette chronologie et que je devrais avoir
et j'y reviendrai plus tard
est le moment où nous avons découvert
spectromètres de masse qui permettent
isotopicité puisque ces isotopes
l'analyse sont absolument cruciales pour
reconstituer les températures du passé
il y a donc un autre élément extrêmement important
date qui est la séminase
c'est à partir de ce moment que nous sommes
capable d'analyser les sédiments
ou en général des échantillons prélevés ici et
là sur la croûte terrestre
dont la célèbre glace polaire
et avec l'analyse isotopique reconstruire
marqueurs des climats passés
c'est dans les années 70 donc je t'ai dit un
les gaz à effet de serre ont une action extrêmement simple
définition
c'est un gaz dont l'absorption se situe dans
l'infrarouge terrestre
c'est la définition d'une serre
gaz il s'avère que ce physique
propriété
n'est accessible qu'aux gaz qui
triatomique ou plus
donc gaz diatomiques ou monoatomiques sens
un gaz noble
ne peut pas avoir de raies d'absorption dans
infrarouge terrestre
donc l'oxygène est transparent pour le
l'azote infrarouge terrestre est
transparent avec infrarouge terrestre
et argon 2. d'autre part vous avez
vapeur d'eau triatomique qui a
lignes d'absorption vous avez du dioxyde de carbone
triatomique qui a des lignes d'oestrogène
vous avez du méthane qui a cinq atomes
qui a des lignes d'absorption
oxyde d'azote qui a également une absorption
lignes
et nous reviendrons sur tout cela
et des gaz qui sont de pures invitations lego
inventé par les hommes
que nous appelons halocarbures ce sont
hydrocarbures
dans lequel nous avons substitué tout ou partie
d'un hydrogène par une molécule d'halogène
donc donc chlore fluorure brome
etc nous verrons pourquoi nous faisons cela
qui sont aussi extrêmement puissants
gaz à effet de serre et enfin il y a
un dernier gaz qui est un gaz à effet de serre
qui est l'ozone
l'ozone est le couteau suisse de l'absorption
ça fait tout
il absorbe les infrarouges terrestres ou il
sait absorber terrestre
infrarouges pour être plus précis
et il sait aussi absorber les
les ultraviolets du soleil d'accord
il fait tout ce que je vous ai dit
l'effet de serre est quelque chose
naturel sur terre puisque vous en avez deux
des gaz
naturellement présent dans l'atmosphère
qui sont des gaz à effet de serre
donc la vapeur d'eau et le co2 est un fin méthane
trop désolé donc tu as
effet de serre sur terre depuis que vous
avoir dans l'atmosphère
co2 méthane et vapeur d'eau
c'est-à-dire depuis
quatre milliards et demi d'années au début
l'atmosphère de la terre était notamment
formé par l'activité volcanique
ce qui a conduit à un important dégazage de co2 donc
dans le primitif
atmosphère de la terre que vous avez déjà
co2 donc l'effet de serre est une histoire
tous les quatre milliards et demi d'années
la terre
d'ailleurs cet effet de serre
car il est dû au volcanisme primaire
activité
nous avons une autre planète qui a aussi
créé une atmosphère
dans lequel il y a beaucoup de planète
il a une densité de matière qui est
près du nôtre
qui est Vénus donc Vénus avait vraisemblablement un
atmosphère primitive qui
formé comme le nôtre sauf que depuis vénus
n'a pas eu
La vie n'a jamais eu l'atmosphère
changements que nous avons vécus
sur terre avec d'abord l'apparition de
méthane dû aux bactéries primitives
appelé
archées puis apparition d'oxygène
avec le primitif
puis des plantes plus développées qui mangeaient du co2
et qui
créé de l'oxygène de sorte que l'atmosphère de
Vénus
a encore 90 à 95 de co2
et à la surface de Vénus avec 90 à
de co2 tu as une jolie serre cosy
effet puisque la température de surface
dépasse 400 degrés
la différence entre vénus et la terre
c'est aussi que l'angle d'interception
de Vénus
est plus important puisque Vénus est plus proche
au soleil mais si tu regardes l'impact
de cet angle d'interception plus grand de sorte que le
fait que
vénus est plus proche du soleil sur le
température d'équilibre, vous n'aurez que
trouver quelques dizaines de degrés
alors bonne nouvelle pour vous ce n'est pas la
exercice qui vous donnera pour la fin
de ce cours
donc ça n'explique pas pourquoi tu as 400
degrés de plus par rapport au
température planétaire ce qui explique
ces 400 degrés de plus
pour la plupart est la serre
effet de vénus
extrêmement puissant depuis que vous m'avez
répéter plus de 90
de co2 dans l'atmosphère donc je ne le fais pas
pense que tu verras jamais ça dans
ta vie ou je ne le ferai pas non plus
question
mais c'est juste là pour montrer que
l'intensification de la serre
effet
peut très très fortement changer la
climat des planètes
ça peut très fortement le changer les hommes
a donc une action aujourd'hui sur le
composition atmosphérique et la façon dont vous
il a cette action
est à travers ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc la première serre la plus importante
gaz que nous émettons et je vous dirai plus tard comment
nous calculons l'importance
est le dioxyde de carbone ou co2
dioxyde de carbone vous avez ici ses cinq
planétaire
causes d'origine humaine
la première est la déforestation pourquoi
la déforestation émet du co2
qu'est-ce que la déforestation en pratique ouais
donc quand on déboise ça veut dire qu'on
éliminer la forêt
donc il y avait des arbres et nous les avons coupés ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
la plupart du temps on les brûle ouais donc le plus gros
une partie de la déforestation est défrichée
mais c'est pour dire qu'on coupe la forêt pour
installer agricole
mais services lorsque le bois coupé est utilisé
en fait seulement une petite partie d'un bois qui
vivra longtemps
dans une forêt française tu n'as que sept
pourcentage d'un arbre coupé
c'est du bois à longue durée de vie
autre
il ira dans des produits qui
soit avoir un très
courte durée de vie généralement du papier
emballage etc ou avoir un délai raisonnablement court
durée de vie pour déclarer la pièce ikea de
meubles
qui ne survivra pas bien dans
général les meubles ikea ne vont pas
à
voir donc là donc ça va dans les produits
qui sont relativement de courte durée
et une fois que le produit a terminé sa vie
le carbone retourne dans le
ambiance car en général c'est
brûlé oui
oui c'est totalement négligeable donc
là vous trouverez deux choses c'est à
en même temps le carbone
qui était contenue dans l'arbre qui
finira dans l'atmosphère parce que
encore une fois, il est essentiellement brûlé
je répondrai à vos questions en deux
secondes et la deuxième chose que vous
trouverez, c'est que lorsque vous transformez
forêt
sol dans le sol agricole vous êtes
aller labourer
en labourant on expose l'humus à
oxygène dans l'air
et donc tu détruiras le carbone
par oxydation accélérée
donc vous diminuez la teneur en carbone de
le sol et ces deux processus sont-ils
ajoutés ensemble qui causent le co2
émissions provenant de la déforestation
oui sur l'axe des ordonnées vous avez
des millions de tonnes donc ce sont des milliards
de tonnes donc si vous enlevez les trois zéros
tu as des milliards de tonnes
oui désolé j'aurais dû préciser
donc vous avez ici la déforestation ce que vous
peut remarquer, c'est que la déforestation
est passé pour une entreprise de quelques personnes au maximum
il y a des décennies et cela continue toujours et
c'est très important mais la raison pour laquelle
vous avez
grandes fluctuations ici quand vous ne l'avez pas fait
en avoir avant c'est juste ça
maintenant nous avons des statistiques je veux dire que c'est un
biais de dépistage essentiellement donc nous avons
statistiques
de pas de temps plus courts que ceux que nous avions
avant donc avant qu'il ne déménage
en outre évaluer la déforestation
est statistiquement un
problème beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
semble parce que c'est essentiellement fait
avec observation satellitaire
mais si vous déboisez sur une parcelle qui est
en dessous de la résolution
en dessous du pixel de l'image vous n'avez pas
voir si vous supprimez
tous les autres arbres et que les couronnes de
les arbres restent à peu près comme eux
étaient avant que vous ne puissiez pas le voir il y a
beaucoup de choses que vous ne pouvez pas voir sur
l'imagerie satellite afin de savoir exactement comment
beaucoup d'arbres nous avons coupé
peut être plus compliqué qu'il n'y parait
alors vous avez ici
un deuxième terme qui est le dioxyde de carbone
qui vient de l'utilisation du charbon
donc utiliser du charbon comme du pétrole comme du gaz
référez-vous à ce que je vous ai dit la dernière fois
est une réaction exothermique provoquée par
oxydation
donc vous prenez un composé de carbone et
l'hydrogène c'est ce qu'on appelle un hydrocarbure
dans des proportions variables beaucoup de carbone
liquides solides moyennement carbonés
peu de gaz carbonique et vous l'oxydez
et cela vous donne une réaction exothermique
qui vous permettra d'alimenter des machines
c'est donc le dioxyde de carbone qui vient
du charbon, du pétrole et du gaz
et puis il y a une chose appelée chaux
calcination
et en français so hallucination of
calcaire pourquoi faisons-nous une telle chose
rendre le ciment absolument si calcaire
quelle est la formule du calcaire
Le ciment caco3 est essentiellement
citron vert avec tout un tas
de poudre de fée que tu ajoutes à la brume
un peu d'argile un peu de mar
un peu de n'importe quoi et c'est pourquoi
qui a déjà fait de la maçonnerie ici
Eh bien, vous avez remarqué que si vous ne le faites pas
mettre des gants à la fin de la journée
la peau de tes doigts est toute abîmée
parce que le ciment comme c'est de la chaux vive plus
poussière de fée ça t'attaque c'est un
accident
alors ouais ça agresse ta peau alors
les liants hydrauliques en général attaquent votre
peau
faire du cao à partir de caco3 c'est très simple
tu prends une grosse paire de ciseaux et
tu le coupes en deux
donc tu prends caco3 tu mets cao sur un
côté et co2 de l'autre
alors c'est quoi cette grosse paire de ciseaux
qui permet de casser la molécule
dans ça s'appelle un four
dans lequel vous apportez le calcaire à un
un peu plus de mille degrés
donc comme dans les indestructibles 1000 degrés
alors
vous obtenez d'un côté le cao et de l'autre
autre co2
évidemment le co2 tu ne fais rien
avec ça pour qu'il aille juste dans le
atmosphère
et ce que vous avez ici sous la chaux
calcination c'est le co2 de la
four à ciment qui vient de cette rupture
de la molécule de carbonate de calcium dans
demi
il n'inclut pas le co2 du
l'énergie dont vous avez besoin pour chauffer le four
ce n'est pas dedans c'est en plus
là
est juste la calcination de la chaux donc ici je
te donner un
voir par source et maintenant je vais vous donner un
voir
selon les zones
c'est un peu plus long pour une échelle de temps
puisqu'ici on commence à 1750 en étranger
j'étais le voisin
voyez-vous qu'à cette époque les émissions
il n'y avait pas tant que ça nous sommes encore
peu
encore quelques-uns et nous verrons comment
les émissions évoluent dans le temps
donc ce que vous voyez, c'est que vous avez ici dans
bleu
émissions d'anciennement industrialisés
des pays
ici les pays de l'ocde qui augmentent qui
augmenter qui augmenter
dans laquelle 10 depuis le pic d'énergie de
dont j'ai parlé
l'avant-dernière fois
donc pour se stabiliser ici
ici en jaune tu as l'ancien
bloc communiste c'est ce que nous appelons
économies en transition
ici en vert vous avez l'asie et en
Chine particulière
et vous pouvez voir qu'aujourd'hui il a
dépassé la zone ocde mais qui est allé
extrêmement vite
et enfin en orange et marron vous avez
autres pays
vous pouvez aussi voir que euh là
mais il y a quelques petites indentations sur
cette courbe pour que vous puissiez voir
la récession de 1929 vous voyez ce que c'est
vous donne un changement annuel
ce qui signifie euh vous pouvez voir un vers le bas
coup vers le bas
et dans la tendance qui ne tient pas beaucoup
rappelons toutefois que tant la crise du 29
bien plus exactement à son peroxisme
c'est-à-dire l'année 1932
et le paroxysme de la seconde guerre mondiale
cela signifie l'éradication industrielle de
Allemagne et Japon en 1945
ce sont les deux seuls épisodes de la
20ième siècle
lorsque les émissions annuelles ont diminué de quatre
pour cent ou plus
il y a eu deux ans au cours du 20e
siècle où les émissions annuelles
diminué
de quatre pour cent c'est 1932 et 1945
alors rappelez-vous parce que si nous sommes sérieux sur
les accords de paris
nous devrions le faire chaque année à partir de maintenant
à partir de la semaine prochaine jusqu'à ce que tu aies mon âge
chaque année nous devons faire chaque année dans
le monde un effort qui est du même
ordre de grandeur que ce que nous avons obtenu
durant
ces deux années ne rigolez pas ça ira
à toi de le faire
ici t'as un choc pétrolier donc tu vois euh
je ne répéterai pas ce qui a causé
dit mais je pense à très
fortement ici vous avez un peu
récession
ça n'a pas duré très longtemps voilà
une croissance très forte qui est la
décollage industriel de la chine
et d'autre part vous avez ici
quelque chose de très efficace
dans la réduction des émissions qui est la
effondrement économique des pays communistes
après la chute du mur ça marche très
très bien et tu verras
la prochaine fois ça marche malheureusement
très très bien signifie que cela pourrait
finalement travailler
respecter le fait que le monde est
bien parce que pour les moments où nous pouvions nous
avoir un drame dans l'histoire qui est ceci
je vous ai montré dans la première leçon que
plus de pib
signifie en fait un flux plus productif qui
le débit était par définition mesuré par
énergie
donc cela signifiait plus d'énergie et puisque
l'énergie est essentiellement fossile c'est à dire
plus de co2
donc ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique est le
drame des négociations sur le climat c'est un
tragédie comme le dit la célèbre citation
parce que faire moins d'émissions de co2 donc
massivement aujourd'hui
personne ne sait même pas moi comment concevoir
ce
sans faire une baisse significative du pib
personne ne sait comment faire cela aujourd'hui et
on y reviendra mais en gros
personne ne sait comment faire ça
donc le drame des négociations climatiques est
là et je ne sais pas qui dans cette pièce
sait prêtre
les gens de l'outil à l'arrière ne font que plaisanter
donc bryce lalonde était écologiste
candidat
donc il a fait ses trois pour cent des voix dans
La France à la fois
quand non seulement tu n'es pas né mais moi
n'était pas vieux
il était ambassadeur du climat de francis et il
était notamment à copenhague eh bien nous étions
dans
ensemble à copenhague en 2009 et il
est allé voir tous les flics
donc très simple et de plus si le
étudiants qui organisent des conférences ici
veux l'inviter à une conférence
journée
c'est un très bon orateur et il a
manières très colorées et vives de raconter
un milliard d'anecdotes
et donc la Grèce a dit un jour sachant qu'il est
fait tous les flics depuis le début il a dit
le problème dans les négociations sur le climat
est-ce que depuis le début
les pays occidentaux viennent penser
on va parler climat
et les pays en développement viennent
pensant que nous allons parler de
développement et développement
là parce que je te le rappelle
ici parce que ce n'est pas une démonstration
c'est un rappel aujourd'hui
nous ne savons pas comment faire plus de pib
sans utiliser plus de machines et
pour plus d'énergie et ainsi de suite
nous verrons dans les leçons à venir si nous
ne peut utiliser que de l'énergie à faible émission de carbone et
tu verras que ce n'est pas si simple
ici vous avez la trajectoire du co2
émissions en france
donc tu vois que dans les séries longues ben on
sont plus ou moins
comme les autres il était petit il a
augmenté, il y a eu des accidents, etc. aucun
des accidents empêchent réellement
augmenter tant que le
la production économique augmente il y a une chose
volva est venu
le game down c'est le nucléaire français
programme que vous pouvez voir ici
cependant maintenant les émissions dès que nous aurons
l'opportunité de faire croître le pib
c'est ce que nous aimerions faire si
nous sommes au gouvernement en ce moment
on ne s'en sort pas bien mais ce n'est pas
parce que nous voulons
eh bien les émissions ont tendance à commencer
augmente à nouveau aussi
ce graphique provient du dernier ic ipcc
rapport
et ça donne la contrepartie je dirais
de la variation des émissions sur la
quatre dernières décennies
en fonction de c'est l'équation de kaya
en fait si
qui ici connaît déjà l'équation kaya
personne de bien
donc tu ne t'ennuieras pas trop la prochaine fois
l'euh l'équation de kaya est une équation
qui décompose les émissions de co2 en
quatre termes
qui sont respectivement le PIB de la population par
la personne
l'intensité énergétique du pib et du co2
efficacité de l'énergie
et ce que disent ces quatre barres ici est
ce
vous avez eu un taux de variation des émissions
toujours positif
donc une croissance des émissions au cours de la dernière
quatre décennies qui est la
triangle tu as là mais ça casse
vers le bas dans
une amélioration de l'efficacité énergétique
de l'économie qui est la barre jaune
une amélioration de l'efficacité carbone
de l'économie
au cours des trois premières décennies de cette
graphique mais pas la dernière décennie
comme vous pouvez le voir ici, il se détériore dans
en fait c'est le boom industriel de la chine
et le boom du charbon
et vous avez les deux autres termes qui
sont la population et la production par personne
en d'autres termes, plus nous sommes tous
nos choses étant égales
plus on émet c'est euh malheureusement
arithmétique et aussi plus nous créons
flux physiques basés sur des machines par
la personne
c'est le plus de pib que nous créons par
personne plus d'énergie
nous utilisons
plus nous émettons donc en d'autres termes
au cours des quatre dernières décennies
la croissance démographique et l'augmentation
de
transformation environnementale par personne
au pib par personne
sont allés plus vite que les gains
que vos prédécesseurs du même
l'école a pu faire
dans les machines que nous utilisons pour vivre
c'est-à-dire la quantité de co2 que nous
mettre à l'air quand on utilise un kilowatt
heure
et la quantité de machines ou la quantité
de kilowattheures que nous devons
utiliser pour faire un dollar de valeur ajoutée tous
droit
ces deux paramètres techniques ont
constamment changé
plus lentement dans le bon sens que
les deux paramètres qui poussent les émissions
up ont évolué dans l'autre sens
petit zoom sur la déforestation tu vois ça
les zones qui ont été dégelées sont
pas la même selon l'heure
vous voyez en particulier qu'un siècle et
il y a un demi le champion du monde de
la déforestation était l'amérique du nord
aujourd'hui champion du monde de
la déforestation est plus l'asie du sud-est
après avoir été l'amérique latine pendant un
longue durée
cependant il y a encore de la déforestation dans
de nombreux pays dans le monde
la déforestation a deux très simples
déterminants
mais d'abord depuis qu'on déboise pour augmenter
la terre arable
le premier déterminant est la taille d'un
population
donc plus une population augmente, plus
en plus on déboise très simple
et le deuxième déterminant est le plus
viande un régime a plus vous aurez besoin
de vastes zones agricoles pour nourrir
les animaux que tu vas manger
au lieu de manger directement les plantes
qui grandissent
et donc plus vous avez de surface par personne
ou plutôt
plus vous avez besoin d'une zone importante par
la personne
qui est évidemment pris là où il peut être
pris pour dire dans la forêt donc je suis
va le dire dans un plus
façon résumée et brutale il y a deux
pilotes deux déterminants essentiels de
déforestation c'est l'augmentation de la
population et l'augmentation de la viande
contenu
dans l'alimentation donc il y a ce sont les
deux déterminants essentiels de
la déforestation
j'ai montré oui
parce qu'il y avait moins de choses à couper donc
en europe la couverture forestière minimale i
l'a dit lors de la première leçon c'était
couverture de la surface européenne en 1850
et nous avons arrêté la déforestation parce que
essentiellement il n'y avait plus rien à
Couper
parce que 15 c'est à peu près donner ou prendre
les forêts qui couvrent
les montagnes aux très hautes latitudes
etc essentiellement où vous ne voulez pas aller
et faire pousser les choses
mais tous les deux ont été décongelés le
tout l'avion aquitain a été
déboisé la terre forêt a
replanté par la suite mais donc essentiellement
Quel
quand vous avez tous les avions qui sont
occupé tu t'arrêtes
à quelques exceptions bien sûr mais
en gros ça y est il y en avait un autre
question
d'accord ouais
en d'autres termes lorsque vous trouvez un équilibre
entre la population et les terres arables
domaines
vous arrêtez de déboiser donc soit ça
l'équilibre est trouvé par limitation disons
dire par famine
donc à un moment donné les surfaces arables dans
les rendements signifient que vous ne pouvez pas augmenter
la taille d'une population
donc tu as déprimé tout ce qui
pourrait être déboisé sauf montagne et
des choses comme ça bien en fait même ça
vous pouvez reporter à de petites cultures
des terrasses comme dans
le sept ou le point d'équilibre est
avant de
et donc surtout aux états-unis
une des choses qui aussi pour ainsi dire
sauve la forêt sont des tracteurs et
les engrais
parce que quand tu augmentes le recadrage
rendements par hectare, vous n'avez pas à aller
chercher des services ailleurs
et d'ailleurs quand on dit qu'on a
faire de l'agriculture extensive
cela ramène le problème de
la déforestation
puisque si vous avez le même régime d'un
moindre
surface productive dont vous avez besoin
plus de surface donc ici vous avez un
conflit d'utilisation évident
en fait plus d'un conflit objectif
pour être exact entre
trois choses qui sont la production de viande
engrais phytosanitaires rémanents et
la déforestation donc c'est compliqué
chose
ici vous avez une autre façon de voir
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui sont
pas les émissions de gaz à effet de serre euh
[Musique]
de la population dans son ensemble mais qui
sont les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
par personne donc par personne vous allez
pour bien me dire c'est évident
il était extrêmement faible au début de
l'ère industrielle et a explosé par la suite
si vous regardez le co2 qui provient
les énergies fossiles oui
depuis le marqueur de l'ère industrielle
c'est justement d'avoir utilisé des machines qui
mangez des combustibles fossiles si vous ajoutez le co2 de
la déforestation
vous voyez alors que vous changez complètement
l'image
en un siècle et demi émissions de co2
par personne ont été multipliés en
devis
seulement par deux et demi
seulement par deux ans et demi
la même période la population humaine a
été multiplié
par six ou cinq
pour que vous puissiez voir que les émissions de co2
par personne
ont augmenté mais euh les émissions liées
à la déforestation ont fortement diminué
et évidemment les autres ont compensé
cette diminution
petit zoom sur la france ici vous avez le
émissions de co2 tricolores
non seulement tricolore comme notre drapeau mais
ce sont vraiment des couleurs libres sur ce graphique
tu remarques qu'aujourd'hui ils sont plus bas
que
ils étaient à l'époque de la première huile
choc
nous avons moins d'émissions de co2 et vous voyez
en particulier que celles de pétrole
et le charbon ont fortement diminué
le pétrole a été chassé de
utilisations industrielles et partiellement hors de
chauffage
par le gaz et l'électricité
le charbon a été chassé de l'industrie
utilise pour deux raisons
la première est qu'une fois que la france avait
fini de construire son infrastructure
nous devions produire moins d'acier et un
des gros consommateurs de charbon est l'acier
industrie
nous avons produit moins d'électricité à partir du charbon
est la deuxième raison et nous avons utilisé moins dans
L'industrie
par contre tu vois que le gaz
tendance à augmenter ses émissions de co2
en fait ça a cessé d'être vrai
depuis le milieu
années 2000 donc vous voyez que nous avons encore
avoir une forte tendance sur ce graphique
alors quand tu oui
ce sont des émissions brutes il n'y a pas
absorption des forêts là-dedans
ce sont vraiment des émissions brutes
le comptage des puits est un
chose indescriptible et je vais en parler
c'est rapide mais c'est très compliqué
chose
donc les émissions brutes de co2 ce que je voulais
te montrer c'est ça
en france ils ont tendance à baisser depuis euh
les chocs pétroliers
si euh oh et au fait si tu vois dans
le journal
ah les émissions ont augmenté par rapport
à l'année dernière
dans l'optique de la longue série mais je
vous montrer ici ce que vous pouvez en déduire
ce
non tu ne déduis rien quand tu es
regarder un
longue série évolution vous
voir qu'il y a des petites choses qui vont
de petites choses qui descendent ces
les choses qui montent ces choses descendent
etc
quand tu as ce genre de choses
seule conclusion dont tu peux sortir
c'est
rien ça n'empêche les gens qui
veux te donner des nouvelles pour te dire que
c'est à cause de ceci c'est à cause de cela
c'est à cause de quelque chose et cetera dans
fait
sur un an, vous obtenez essentiellement le
conclusion qu'attendons de voir
donc c'est évidemment ennuyeux ce que je suis
vous dire parce que dans un monde qui est
gouverné
par réaction à court terme ne pouvant pas
attribut
des causes précises à ce que nous observons
est ennuyeux
alors là tu as la même chose
discriminé par
secteur d'utilisation
donc il y a quelques choses qui sont tout à fait
frappant sur ce graphisme
vous voyez d'abord que l'ordre dans lequel
les émissions arrivent aujourd'hui est absolument
pas l'ordre dans lequel ils sont arrivés
lors d'un maximum à l'huile
choc à
cette fois la plupart de l'utilisation je veux dire du co2
émissions
était le travail de l'industrie et pas du tout
des transports comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
vous pouvez voir que les émissions de co2 de
l'industrie à l'origine des chocs pétroliers
a fortement chuté, ce qui est une autre façon de
dire que
l'industrie est le secteur dans lequel
la consommation est
le plus sensible au prix et savez-vous pourquoi
parce que brillant d'un méchant paritek
ingénieur universitaire comme toi
sont dans votre vie personnelle, vous
compte beaucoup moins soigneusement ce que tu fais
que dans votre vie professionnelle
donc dans la vie personnelle les gens sont beaucoup
moins sensible malgré ce que tu es
enseigné en économie
nous ne sommes pas seulement des êtres rationnels et
donc tu es
beaucoup moins sensible aux variations de prix
que l'on peut être dans les entreprises où nous
Fabriquer
beaucoup de calculs extrêmement intelligents pour
savoir si nous ne pouvons pas
gagner trois cents ici plutôt que de perdre contre
là et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
le secteur industriel est beaucoup plus sensible
aux variations de prix que le secteur privé
il réagit plus vite et de plus vous pouvez
voir que la même variation d'huile
prix appliqués à l'industrie ici
est un changeur de jeu bien là c'est à peine
change quoi que ce soit de bon l'ancienne consommation
dans les transports évolué
avant et après à peu près pareil
bien après avoir un deuxième endroit où
ça commence à bouger considérablement
ce sont les industries de l'énergie qui sont
centrales électriques et raffineries
et c'est essentiellement le travail de
centrales électriques, nous avions de plus en plus
plus de charbon
le pétrole et le gaz dans les centrales électriques et maintenant
nous avons de moins en moins surtout de pétrole et
nous commençons à tout remplacer par
nucléaire
vous voyez l'effet ici vous le voyez aussi
dans les bâtiments
donc résidentiel et euh et tertiaire
effectivement dans les chaudières des bâtiments pour
être exact, il commence également à diminuer
et le seul secteur dans lequel il a
a continué d'augmenter est le transport
cependant vous voyez que dans le transport il
a tendance à diminuer depuis le milieu
2000 et ce n'est pas dû au climat
sensibilisation
parce que c'est un effet qui se voit dans
tous nos pays européens
à peu près en même temps c'est un effet
sur la contrainte régionale en liquide
approvisionnement en hydrocarbures
dont je vous ai parlé dans le précédent
bien sûr c'est un effet de ça
si on prend tous les gaz à effet de serre combinés
C'est comme ça
distribué pour que vous ayez toujours le transport
qui vient en premier
mais d'un autre côté si tu regardes
attention tu vois
ici l'agriculture c'est tout le chemin
bas et ici l'agriculture va beaucoup
plus haut je n'entrerai pas dans les détails
pour le moment parce que je reviendrai
après mais c'est lié au fait
qu'il émet
d'autres gaz que juste le euh
co2 qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce le
club de théâtre à côté donc je vais juste
lui demander de faire un peu moins de bruit
ou fermer la porte ouais je pense que nous devrions
résoudre le problème
revenons donc au sujet en question
la quantité de co2 dans l'air est
Je t'ai montré
plus tôt j'y reviendrai plus tard
expliquant comment cela est mesuré sur
longues périodes
cette quantité croissante de co2, nous avons un
cause naturelle qui pourrait entraîner sa
augmenter je l'ai mentionné plus tôt qui
est
c'est parce que ça a fait apparaître le co2
dans l'atmosphère primitive de la Terre
oui volcanisme si le co2 apparaît dans le
air
du volcanisme en ce moment
quand j'ai une augmentation de la quantité
de co2 dans l'air
ai-je une raison particulière pour
observant une diminution corrélative de la
contient de l'oxygène
oui ou non non
ce que vous voyez ici est la variation de
la quantité de co2 dans
air avec en fait la variation saisonnière
et ici vous avez la variation dans le
quantité d'oxygène dans l'air c'est
évidemment une échelle extrêmement dépensée
et vous voyez qu'il y a aussi un
variation saisonnière
alors savez-vous ce que la saison
la variation est
non tu as toujours le droit d'appeler un
ami en 50 50.
Ouais non
c'est saisonnier donc pas le jour la nuit
ouais exactement donc tu sais que la terre
a deux hémisphères qui sont
très asymétrique par rapport à
surfaces émergées vous avez beaucoup plus
surfaces émergées dans le nord
hémisphère que dans l'hémisphère sud
hémisphère
ce qui veut dire que quand c'est le printemps
dans l'hémisphère nord
et où poussent les plantes
végétation
pompera le co2 de l'atmosphère tout en
d'un autre côté
dans l'hémisphère sud, vous avez un
beaucoup moins de plantes qui
euh avec un feuillage caduc
qui aura des feuilles qui pourriront
ce qui signifie que le co2
reviendra dans l'atmosphère car dans
en fait une feuille pourrie est une feuille qui
se décompose sous l'action microbienne et
les microbes respirent comme vous le faites
respiration microbienne mettre du co2
de retour dans l'atmosphère comme q microbes
absorbent l'oxygène et libèrent du co2
alors quand c'est le printemps et l'été dans le
hémisphère nord
le contenu en co2 d'un planétaire
l'atmosphère a tendance à légèrement baisser
et d'autre part quand c'est l'automne
en hiver dans l'hémisphère nord le
la teneur en co2 de l'atmosphère tend à
légèrement ré-augmenter et ainsi autour de la
tendance majeure
qui est tiré par nos émissions de co2
tu as un
oscillation saisonnière que vous voyez très
très bien dans les mesures
sur la teneur en co2 si la saisonnalité
la variation va corrélativement
avec une oscillation saisonnière de l'oxygène
et cela
euh et qu'en plus la tendance lourde de
l'oxygène est une légère baisse
dans sa concentration, cela signifie que tout
molécule de co2 qui apparaît
dans l'air a pris une molécule d'oxygène
depuis les airs
nous sommes d'accord et cela signifie donc que cela
le co2 ne pourrait apparaître que par oxydation d'un
carbone qui était disponible pour être oxydé
et vous avez deux endroits où le carbone est
disponible pour être oxydé
vous avez la décomposition de la végétation de
feuilles mortes
mais vous l'avez aussi c'est une tendance la
combustion de combustibles fossiles
et il est normal que la combustion de
les combustibles fossiles enlèvent
ou vous déstockez le carbone sous
le sol et corrélativement
tu vas détruire un peu d'oxygène de
l'ambiance et
vous mettez les deux ensemble et vous donne
plus de co2 alors quelle est cette courbe
sur l'oxygène vous dit, c'est qu'il est en effet
un processus de combustion
ou l'oxydation du carbone pour être plus précis
qui est à l'origine de l'apparition
du surplus de co2 dans l'air
c'est l'une des façons dont nous devons
montre CA
le surplus de co2 qui apparaît dans
atmosphère
vient bien de quelque chose
se passe à la surface d'une planète
pas par exemple du volcanisme il y a
une seconde
l'analyse que nous sommes en mesure de faire à ce sujet
co2 qui montre qu'il
vient en effet de nous c'est euh vous avez
entendu parler d'un
carbone-14
Alors le carbone 14 savez-vous ce que c'est
formé
il se forme par transmutation de l'azote dans
les effets de l'interview dans la haute atmosphère
du rayonnement cosmique
donc sous l'effet du rayonnement cosmique
tu as de l'azote
dans la haute atmosphère qui absorbe i
ne me souviens pas si c'est un
un neutron ou un proton mais il a un
indigestion
et il se transforme en carbone 14. ce carbone
la fortune entre ensuite dans le carbone
cycle et sera ingéré par la vie
êtres
quand vous avez des combustibles fossiles qui sont
anciens êtres vivants
ils sont sous terre depuis des dizaines de
des millions d'années ils ont totalement perdu
leur carbone 14.
donc les émissions de co2 qui proviennent
combustibles fossiles
doit appauvrir l'atmosphère en carbone 14
d'accord ce qui vient de la vie est un
cycle du carbone 14 de courte durée l'arbre
grandit il dure quelques décennies ou quelques
des siècles
il meurt bam il retourne dans le
ambiance c'est trop court
d'un temps pour qu'il change fondamentalement
la teneur en carbone 14 de l'atmosphère
par contre quand tu détruis
combustibles fossiles et vous ajoutez du co2 qui
lui-même est complètement appauvri en carbone
il modifie le contenu isotopique du
atmosphère
en carbone 14. et c'est aussi quelque chose
que nous observons en ce moment
et c'est aussi quelque chose qui nous permet
dire que l'augmentation du co2 dans le
l'ambiance vient bien de nous
donc je vais sauter ça parce que je
n'a pas le temps et ce n'est pas le
le plus important
oui question
non c'est beaucoup trop imperceptible
je l'ai dit plus tôt l'échelle est élargie nous
parlent de parties par million
donc nous parlons pour le co2 de faire le
la teneur en co2 change de 0,03
à 0,04 ou 0,05
de co2 dans l'atmosphère si vous enlevez
0,01
ou 0,02 de l'oxygène de la
atmosphère
cela fait une différence de pression partielle
sur l'oxygène qui est
beaucoup plus faible que lorsque vous allez skier et
tu as observé que
tu reviens vivant du bon ski
jusqu'à maintenant en tout cas
alors et ne riez pas mikhail
n'a pas été très chanceux alors euh
ça tellement tellement cette diminution
la teneur en oxygène n'est pas suffisante pour
c'est un problème
d'autre part l'augmentation du
teneur en co2 de l'atmosphère
à des niveaux plus élevés que ceux que nous sommes
parler aujourd'hui mais pas considérablement
plus haut
ça peut devenir un vrai problème aujourd'hui là
sont des gens qui regardent
que ce soit à mille ppm de co2 dans le
atmosphère que nous ne commençons pas à avoir
problèmes de santé récurrents pour absolument
tout le monde
alors aujourd'hui je vous rappelle qu'on est à 400.
ce qui est certain c'est qu'à 10 de co2 dans
l'atmosphère vous mourez tous
depuis euh il y a une toxicité aiguë au co2
et ce n'est pas seulement parce que tu t'étouffes
je peux te donner 20
d'oxygène en même temps c'est juste un
toxicité aiguë
co2 dans l'atmosphère il vaut mieux pas
en avoir trop
vous avez également remarqué que je suis sûr que lorsque
tu es dans une ambiance vicié si c'est pour
dire dans une pièce qui n'est pas bien
ventilé
vous pouvez avoir un peu mal à la tête c'est
un des effets possibles du co2
donc j'y reviens le co2 est un oxyde
dioxyde de carbone vous savez quoi parce que vous
l'a appris en chimie
que les oxydes sont des molécules qui sont
extrêmement stable
un oxyde est très stable le fer que nous
trouver aujourd'hui
sous forme de fp2o3
dans les gisements de minerai de fer, il a été
des milliards d'années je veux dire comme depuis le
les continents sont apparus
et que le fer oxydé il a été
des milliards d'années qu'il est
sous forme d'oxyde de fer et il suffit
reste comme ça parce que c'est euh
extrêmement stable donc cette stabilité de
co2 est la stabilité chimique
s'applique également au co2 que nous mettons dans le
atmosphère une fois le co2
est mis dans l'atmosphère que vous n'avez pas
un procédé chimique
purger ce gaz
il n'y a tout simplement pas de processus chimique
purger le co2 de l'atmosphère
vous n'avez que deux processus de nettoyage
et j'y reviendrai plus tard
quels sont les processus physiques que le co2 peut
se dissoudre dans l'eau de mer en fait c'est un
équilibrage des pressions partielles entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan
et le co2 peut être photosynthétisé
ce qui signifie qu'il peut être bien absorbé
plus exactement métabolisé par une plante mais
c'est un
réaction endothermique donc vous avez besoin d'un
photon
si spontanément vous n'avez pas de
réaction chimique
de costume avec quoi que ce soit d'autre dans le
atmosphère
le corollaire de cette affaire est que
une fois que
le co2 est mis dans l'atmosphère
en fait une fois le surplus de co2 mis
dans l'atmosphère pour être précis
son temps d'amortissement le temps qu'il vous faut
attendre l'excès de co2 pour
évacuer
après l'arrêt des émissions est
extrêmement élevé donc ce que vous voyez ici
est-ce une fois que vous euh
[Musique]
une fois que vous arrêtez les émissions
donc tu attends et plus d'émissions bien
ce que ce graphique vous dit, c'est que
un siècle plus tard, vous avez 40 à 50
pour cent de l'excédent qui reste
au-dessus de vos têtes
donc un siècle plus tard ce n'est même pas ton
chefs vous serez tous morts
mille ans plus tard tu seras encore
avoir autour
vingt pour cent de l'excédent je vais
être toujours au-dessus de nos têtes
et dix mille ans plus tard tu
ont encore environ dix pour cent d'un
le surplus sera toujours au-dessus de nos têtes
donc ce que je vous dis c'est que
processus de changement climatique
n'a pas de réversibilité aucune
d'accord, il n'y a pas de bouton de réinitialisation qui
pourra appuyer un jour alors que
dire de la merde
si j'avais su je ne serais pas venu et
qui
permettrait de recommencer
expérimenter dès le départ
vous ne pouvez pas recommencer l'expérience
c'est une expérience qui va se faire
une fois et une seule
et à cause de cela absolument
grande inertie du co2 dans le
atmosphère
une autre chose que vous pouvez déjà garder
à l'esprit à partir de maintenant
est que les conséquences du climat
changement sur lequel je détaillerai un chiffre
de choses
la prochaine fois la seule garantie que vous
avoir est qu'au moment où nous commençons
à
je veux dire nous vous l'humanité au moment où nous
considèrerai
qu'ils sont intolérables les seuls
garantie que nous avons désormais est
que ce sera pire après
à cause de cette stabilité
de dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère tous
droit
oui
on met du co2 car on oxyde du fossile
combustibles
les arbres ne le mangent pas assez vite
parce qu'ils sont limités par
photosynthèse
oui partiellement et
puis dans l'une des conséquences que je
vous parlera de l'un des
conséquences est que vous allez
fragiliser les écosystèmes terrestres
ajout
on aura moins envie de manger du co2 que
avant de
vous avez un certain nombre de retours
processus dans cette affaire que je vais
parler de la prochaine fois quels sont les processus
appelé
positif c'est à dire d'amplification
c'est-à-dire que le premier
conséquences d'un processus seront de
amplifier le processus
et vous en avez un certain nombre que je
détaillerai la prochaine fois
donc ici vous avez évidemment un résultat de
tous les effets de ses émissions
compte tenu du fait qu'il y a
sont des hypothèses
donc j'ai encore dit absorptions toi seulement
avoir deux
équilibrage des pressions partielles entre
l'atmosphère et l'océan c'est physique
une réaction endothermique de
la photosynthèse où vous avez besoin d'un photon
il faut donc de l'énergie
cette affaire sera donc
s'appliquent aux échelles de temps qui
dépasser la compréhension
et surtout qui dépasse
le temps caractéristique de
mandats électoraux dans les démocraties et
qui d'ailleurs ira bien au-delà
stratégie à long terme
de votre futur employeur s'il est répertorié
en bourse
et même d'ailleurs si ce n'est pas
coté en bourse
donc les horizons temporels concernés
dans ce processus
dont je me souviens ce que j'ai dit à la
début ne sont pas accessibles à votre
sens
je rappelle que tu sais je veux dire euh c'est
toutes les moyennes
bien le temps caractéristique de ce
traiter
va bien au-delà de la caractéristique
temps des modes de gestion que nous
ont
disons démocratisé excusez le jeu de mot
à la surface d'une planète qui est celle
que nous avons mis en commun
alors maintenant il n'y a plus que du co2 dans la vie
il y a d'autres missions gaz à effet de serre
j'y arriverai mais le co2 en fait quand je
te dire
il y a une partie du surplus qui va
loin en fait il reste pendant un certain temps et
après que sa concentration diminue
de plus en plus fortement donc vous avez d'autres
gaz pour lesquels l'instantané
l'effet radiatif est beaucoup plus fort
mais ils peuvent éventuellement rester pour différents
échelles de temps et vous avez un gaz
dans ce domaine qui est également important
dans les discussions qui est le méthane
le méthane a un rayonnement instantané
le forçage qui est beaucoup plus important
ce qui signifie que lorsque vous mettez un kilogramme de
méthane dans l'atmosphère qu'il intercepte
bien plus efficacement terrestre
infrarouge
quand tu mets un kilo de co2 sur le
d'autre part le méthane a un produit chimique
processus de nettoyage
hors de l'atmosphère, il est mangé par
radicaux hydroxyles
donc il y restera plus court
temps
c'est donc le seul gaz qui a un
processus de nettoyage chimique hors du
atmosphère que vous avez déjà lapidé
à ce stade, nous savons parce que
je vous ai montré le graphique plus tôt que le
quantité de co2 puisque nous avons
mesures instrumentales sens depuis 1958
augmente rapidement dans l'atmosphère
mais nous ne sommes pas encore en mesure de comparer cela
avec quoi avec ce qui se passe en plus
les temps anciens
donc pour comparer ça avec plus ancien
périodes
nous devrons faire une petite promenade à
les sondages
alors pourquoi devons-nous aller à la
sondages parce qu'au poste versus
quelque chose qui nous intéresse beaucoup
comme des archives climatiques qui sont la glace
casquettes
alors quel est le processus de formation de
calottes glaciaires
nous allons prendre l'Antarctique parce que
ce que je te dis a cessé d'être
vrai pour le Groenland
sur la majeure partie de la surface antarctique, vous
ont des températures qui sont
négatif toute l'année ce qui signifie que
quand il y a des précipitations
il est nécessairement sous forme de neige dans
de toute façon les précipitations sont très rares
l'antarctique étant un endroit très froid c'est
un endroit extrêmement sec
donc vous avez de faibles précipitations chaque année
quand la neige tombe année après année
vous avez des chutes de neige et cette chute de neige comme
ça ne fond pas comme euh vraiment
ne fond jamais ce qui leur arrive c'est que
ils vont compacter
sous le poids des chutes de neige successives
ce processus de compactage après quelques
siècles finit par transformer la neige en
la glace
donc vous avez un processus de
transformer la neige en glace simplement en
effet de pression
au moment où cette neige se transforme en glace
va piéger sous forme de petites bulles
l'air qui circule entre le
flocons de neige
donc tu as de l'air qui circule entre
les flocons et en train de
compactage
cet air est emprisonné sous forme de petites
bulles donc tu vas
trouver dans la glace emprisonné
sous forme de petites bulles le fossile
ambiance datant des dates
de la formation de la glace
après cette glace ne reste pas dans le
même endroit
il s'avère que ce sera en général
flux de règles
vers l'océan d'accord c'est un
processus d'accumulation et par gravité
ou
sous son poids de ses propres yeux
sur de longues échelles de temps glace
est un peu fluide donc ça coule et ça
se termine un peu plus tard
des dizaines de milliers d'années des millions de
des milliers d'années plus tard en donnant
icebergs
alors quand tu vas choisir correctement
l'endroit où le carottage est effectué
parce que c'est ce dont nous allons parler
bientôt eh bien il arrive que
vous avez une petite partie de la glace qui
est
dans ce processus ou dans cette dynamique
s'écoule essentiellement verticalement
donc il coule sans errer vers
la côte ce qui signifie que si vous êtes
va faire le trou à
l'emplacement correct dans une verticale construite
carottage que vous obtiendrez à mesure que la profondeur augmente
glace de plus en plus ancienne signifiant de plus en plus
atmosphère fossile
et toutes les espèces chimiques contenues
dans cette ambiance
qui sont stables une fois que la bulle a
formé ce qui est le cas du co2
c'est tout aussi le cas d'ailleurs
avec du méthane
parce qu'une fois que le méthane n'est plus dans
contact avec les radicaux hydroxyles
de l'atmosphère, il cesse de disparaître
donc méthane
que vous trouvez dans les bulles d'air formées
dans la glace qu'il représente
la concentration de méthane que vous aviez
au moment où la bulle s'est formée
bien en moyenne au fil des siècles
au cours de laquelle il se forme
donc la façon dont nous fabriquons une carotte de glace est très
simple ici vous avez un noyau
donc le noyau tu le mets à la surface
du noyau vous faites un
grand trou de forage et c'est un gros trou et
tu
compris dans la conférence sur le pétrole que
nous sommes les rois bien sûr nous savons très bien
bien comment faire ça
Et voilà, tu récupères la glace
noyau donc voici ce que le
carotte de glace ressemble et qui est beaucoup
plus précieux évidemment que celui
qui finira dans ton whisky
et ici nous le sortons d'un tube
nous allons le couper en petits morceaux
et étiquetez-les soigneusement pour indiquer
chacun à quelle profondeur il a été pris et nous envoyons
qu'au laboratoire de euh
je ne me souviens pas du nom pour l'instant mais
celui de grenoble qui étudie ce
est
dans les carottes de glace donc dans les carottes de glace
nous trouverons deux choses
nous trouverons à la fois la glace elle-même
et en analysant l'isotope
composition de l'eau c'est-à-dire
une fraction d'oxygène 18 ou la fraction
de deutérium dans l'hydrogène de l'eau
nous sommes capables de reconstruire la planète
température d'un temps
parce que quand l'eau t'évapore
avoir ce qu'on appelle
un fractionnement isotopique signifiant que
plus la température à l'endroit est élevée
d'évaporation
plus la vapeur d'eau transporte
proportion plus
oxygène 18 et deutérium
qui est évidemment qui évidemment même
se précipite dans le monde entier
y compris l'Antarctique pour former la neige de
la calotte glaciaire donc l'isotro isotopique
teneur en oxygène 18 et en deutérium dans
yeux d'une casquette est un marqueur d'un planétaire
Température
et tu trouveras de l'air euh de l'air dans le
petites bulles
et l'air dans les petites bulles sera
un marqueur de la teneur en co2 méthane
l'oxyde nitreux fonctionne aussi que vous aviez
dans l'ambiance
des temps anciens oui
comme en antarctique tu trouveras de l'eau
précipiter
après s'être évaporé partout
toute la surface de l'océan
dans l'ensemble c'est un marqueur d'un planétaire
Température
donc pour le co2 c'est aussi un marqueur du
co2 planétaire
car depuis la durée de vie du co2 dans
atmosphère
elle est de l'ordre des siècles et
millénaires je veux dire le surplus de co2
tandis que le temps de mélange inter-hémisphérique
de l'atmosphère est de l'ordre du
an
en gros tu émets du co2 absolument
n'importe où donc je veux dire
j'allais en parler plus tard mais
peu importe donc tu émets du co2
n'importe où et les concentrations seront
homogénéiser très rapidement
et donc puisqu'en plus à cette époque
tu avais
peu de sources de co2 concentrées
susceptible de déranger localement disons
la mesure
parce que si tu avais un volcan juste à côté
à la carotte de glace, ce serait un peu
ennuyeux mais
ce n'est pas le cas et bien vous aurez
un marqueur d'une concentration en co2 dans
ambiance dans son ensemble
donc quand vous analysez la serre euh
concentration de gaz oh désolé non
tu peux faire ça en antarctique tu pourrais
fais ça
Au Groenland autrefois, vous ne pouvez pas
fais plus ça
de nos jours au Groenland parce qu'il y a
sont de nombreux endroits au Groenland où maintenant
la neige fond
à la surface de la calotte glaciaire et ainsi
à partir de là évidemment tu n'es plus
avoir cette année des phénomènes d'accumulation
après un an
ce qui te donne des strat qui tiennent bien
daté dans le temps
une partie de ce qui tombe coule devient l'enfer
hors d'ici etc donc ce n'est pas tout
plus exploitable
donc ce que vous avez ici est le
concentration de co2 méthane et nitreux
oxyde
pas la même compétence mais peu importe
donc vous voyez que jusqu'au début de
l'ère préindustrielle
tout ce qui est stable et l'industriel
l'ère arrive et vous voyez le
concentration qui commence à augmenter
extrêmement rapidement
aujourd'hui nous pouvons revenir avec le plus ancien
cours ou
ou le cours le plus profond pour être plus précis
qui a été collecté en antarctique pour
sur
800 000 ans donc plus de 800 000 ans
nous sommes en mesure de reconstituer
concentration de co2 et de méthane qui
vous avez
ici et j'ai mis pour vous ici
À l'échelle
le surplus de concentrations que nous
ont déjà créé
depuis un siècle et demi ou deux
siècles et ce que vous voyez, c'est qu'à
échelles de temps géologiques
où les variations climatiques ont généré
ou sont allés de pair
avec des variations de gaz à effet de serre
ce cas c'est conducteur astronomique
forçages
qui changent avec la température sur
terre et cela change l'équilibre
concentration de gaz à effet de serre je vais
revenez à cela dans l'accord suivant
donc là tu vois que ça varie un peu
peu mais vous voyez que
nous sommes déjà totalement sortis du
variations naturelles avec ce que nous avons
ajoutée
et les périodes grises ici sont chaudes dans
périodes interglaciaires
comme celle dans laquelle nous avions commencé à vivre
pour les 10 derniers
000 ans et vous voyez qu'il
correspond à des concentrations plus élevées de
gaz à effet de serre
donc en ce qui concerne le co2 c'est le processus
d'éliminer le co2 de l'océan qui est
car l'eau chaude dissout moins bien le co2
que de l'eau froide
alors quand tu as un forçage astronomique
qui chauffe
la température de la planète qu'il réchauffe
les océans
à cette époque les océans se décomposent un peu
plus de co2 et au passage réchauffe la plante
encore plus
à un moment donné, les phénomènes finissent par
coussins et équilibres mais
vous avez un phénomène d'amplification et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la sortie de
la glaciation est beaucoup plus rapide
que l'entrée en glaciation car
vous avez ce phénomène d'amplification
commentaire positif
et en ce qui concerne le méthane, il est
plus chaud
implique plus humide je vous l'ai dit plus tôt
puisqu'il y a une eau qui s'intensifie
faire du vélo à droite
donc plus de zones humides donc plus de méthane
émissions
étant donné que le méthane naturel est principalement émis
par les zones humides
il y a un marqueur de zones humides depuis
produire du méthane naturellement il faut
avoir une zone où la végétation pourrit
de l'oxygène de l'air
généralement des marécages, etc., donc plus vous
augmenter les zones humides et plus vous
augmenter
les émissions de méthane et la question
évidemment
est où allons-nous avec cela dans le
futur donc vous voyez que
avant même de parler de l'avenir
discontinuité
que nous avons introduit dans le
l'ambiance est extrêmement brutale
en ce qui concerne ce qui se passe dans
échelles de temps géologiques
et à cause de la durée de vie du co2
excès dans l'atmosphère
même avec des émissions qui réduisent fortement
demain matin
nous sommes encore très très loin d'avoir
vu la totalité des conséquences
que de ce que nous avons déjà fait tous
droit
nous ne sommes pas dans un système instantané en
dont les conséquences sont immédiates
après les émissions
on verra ça la prochaine fois
répartis sur des milliers d'années
après les émissions d'accord
donc là la question est vous savez où
fais
où s'arrête-t-on
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui et loin de là
la concentration de co2 la plus élevée jamais enregistrée dans
l'atmosphère planétaire
nous avons eu des ères géologiques anciennes où le
concentration de co2
était beaucoup plus élevé qu'aujourd'hui alors vous voici
avoir un marqueur
de la quantité de co2 présente dans
Ambiance depuis le début
de l'ère primaire et s'exprime
en multiples du courant
concentration donc vous voyez que
il y avait des moments où il y avait 20
fois plus de co2 peut-être même
30 fois plus il y a longtemps
mais ces temps correspondaient aussi à
moments où
l'énergie solaire était plus faible
et d'ailleurs à cette époque il y avait
probablement très peu de vie sur émergé
terres
signifiant que les terres émergées étaient
encore essentiellement des déserts
et la vie était essentiellement dans l'océan donc
dans le changement climatique dont nous parlons
à propos d'aujourd'hui mon avis
est que la probabilité que le climat
changement entraînera l'éradication de tous
la vie sur Terre
depuis assez faible pour moi ce qui sera à
pieu
est évidemment là où le curseur se déplace
des endroits où ça va bien et
des endroits où les choses poussent moins
bien
c'est bien la question mais c'est
ne va évidemment pas anéantir tout
la vie sur terre oui
donc la quantité de co2 que je viens d'expliquer
depuis que nous avons des océans la quantité de co2
est contrôlé un peu par
rayonnement solaire depuis quand le rayonnement solaire
rayonnement retenu par la planète
selon la variation de
paramètres astronomiques
est plus important que les océans
réchauffé et il se désintègre un peu de co2
donc là vous avez un processus de pilotage
quand tu as de la végétation qui fait
eh bien c'est ce qui s'est passé après le
apparition de végétation dans
l'ère cambrienne là tu avais euh
en conséquence co2 qui a diminué
là donc vous avez des processus qui sont
lié ainsi
rayonnement solaire la quantité de végétation
et le co2 dans l'air
mais ce qui est important dans ce que je suis
vous dire est la vitesse à laquelle le
le processus évolue
c'est une question de vitesse tout ça
histoire de missile donc pour reprendre et on va
en parler davantage au moment de la
conséquences
si tu vas dans un mur à trois
kilomètres par heure, vous avez une bosse sur
ta tête
et si tu vas à 100 kilomètres à l'heure
tu es mort donc ici
on parle exactement de la même chose
chose il y a des mouvements d'un système
qui ne dérangent pas parce qu'ils
sont faites sur des périodes lentes et
il y a donc des adaptations possibles
et il y a des mouvements d'un système
qui sont plus ennuyeux parce qu'ils sont
réalisées sur des périodes de temps qui
sont trop courts pour que le système s'adapte
bonnes conditions
et malheureusement nous allons pour le
deuxième option c'est ce qui est
gênant
et c'est pourquoi nous devons passer cinq
des heures dessus
donc nous n'avons pas que du co2 dedans
gaz à effet de serre
alors je te l'ai dit plus tôt et j'arrive
y revenir une fois que nous savons qu'il n'y a pas
seulement du co2 dans ce
affaires pour ceux d'entre vous c'est-à-dire
normalement tout le monde si la communauté
fait bien son travail qui sera quelque peu
intéressé par la question du changement climatique
dans leur futur métier car c'est un
chose transversale dont tout le monde doit se soucier
à ce sujet
un peu vous allez avoir besoin d'une métrique
parce qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule serre
gaz s'il n'y avait qu'un seul gaz à effet de serre
ce serait simple la métrique est la
poids de co2
nous n'avons que du co2 nous le mesurons par
poids et c'est pire d'émettre
trois kilogrammes qu'un kilogramme, mais
puisque nous avons plusieurs gaz à effet de serre
méthane dioxyde d'azote, etc. est-ce plus
mauvais d'émettre un kilogramme de méthane ou
un kilogramme de co2 si mon patron me dit
vous avez 1 000 euros pour réduire quelque chose
et que j'ai la possibilité de réduire
méthane de 3% ou co2 de 10%
qu'est-ce que je choisis bien vous ne pouvez pas répondre
cette question
jusqu'à ce que vous ayez une unité de comparaison a
monnaie c'est-à-dire quelque chose qui
permet de dire
c'est x fois plus grave ou x fois
moins grave que le co2
donc cette monnaie s'appelle gwp
le gwp signifie le réchauffement climatique
potentiel
c'est le forçage radiatif cumulatif
qu'une unité de gaz à effet de serre supplémentaire
dans l'atmosphère crée
et plutôt que de le regarder dans
termes absolus, nous avons choisi que ce
unité être une unité relative
c'est donc en fait le rapport entre le
cumulatif
forçage radiatif d'une unité de
gaz à effet de serre sur une période donnée
divisé par le forçage radiatif
sur la même période de même poids
en co2
cela signifie que par convention le gwp de
le co2 est
égal à un quel que soit le moment
horizon d'accord
cette unité dépend de l'horizon temporel
et cela dépend d'un forçage radiatif donc
je reviens au
courbe que je vous ai montrée plus tôt celle-ci
donc tu as vu que si je prends par exemple
ce gaz
qui est un holocarbure et que je limite
mon horizon temporel à un
année bien j'aurai un ratio et ça
est logarithmique donc 10
10 000 fois donc le gwp de ce truc est
10 000 fois le gwp du co2
mais si je limite mon horizon temporel à un
mille ans
eh bien ce truc aura été nettoyé
beaucoup plus rapide que le co2
et donc mon rapport d'intégrales
parce que c'est ce que c'est
rapport des intégrales sur un temps donné
période, il aura une période extrêmement
valeur différente
il y a donc un débat qui peut sembler
peu
technique pour vous comme ennuyeux pointilleux
quelle est la bonne échelle de temps et
ce n'est pas du tout un débat tatillon
car
en fonction de l'échelle de temps que vous
prendre en particulier pour le méthane
donc le méthane à un siècle est 25 fois
plus nocif que le co2
mais à 20 ans c'est environ
80 fois plus nocif que le co2
alors qu'est-ce que je prends 20 ans ou un siècle
bien si je prends 20 ans
la nouvelle-zélande qui émet beaucoup de méthane
parce qu'il a beaucoup de
les moutons et les vaches commencent à crier la même chose pour
pays qui cultivent du riz alors que si je
prendre une sentinelle
ce sont les pays qui ont le plus de co2
dans l'inventaire des émissions
qui commencent à crier en disant non non ceci
me désavantage
alors vous voyez que ce sujet qui peut
sembler un peu technique et anecdotique
en fait, il pilote la façon dont nous
répartira la charge des efforts
en fonction des sources d'émission oui
parce que la hausse croissante émet du méthane je vais
reviens dessus plus tard
eh bien une rizière est un marécage artificiel
donc tu as
débris organiques qui se décomposent loin de
l'oxygène de l'air
donc vous avez une décomposition anaérobie
qui émet du méthane
toutes les décompositions anaérobies émettent
méthane
c'est d'ailleurs le même principe
qui est utilisé de nos jours dans les méthaniseurs
que vous pourriez avoir
entendu dire que nous faisons exactement la même chose que nous
mettre le matériel végétal à l'abri de la
l'oxygène de l'air qui alimente
bactéries primitives appelées
archées qui émettent du méthane
donc une fois que vous avez le
eh bien c'est précisément à propos de ma veine je
J'aurais dû vous dire la diapositive suivante
on pourra donc comparer la serre
les émissions de gaz ici sont par exemple
les émissions de méthane en ce moment je compte
eux dans
tonnes de méthane ou plus exactement en
millions de tonnes de méthane
alors d'où vient le méthane bien vous
l'avoir ici
alors d'abord tu as tellement de rizières
c'est là que le riz est cultivé ici attendez
non
en fait c'est l'extraction du charbon
voici donc la répartition du gaz ces
sont les fuites dans le réseau de gaz
parce que le gaz naturel est du méthane ce sont
les mines de charbon alors référez-vous à ce que j'ai dit
tu es la dernière fois
quand une veine froide se forme il y a du méthane
qui est absorbé sur le charbon
rappelez-vous et donc lors de l'extraction du charbon
le méthane est émis dans l'atmosphère
parce qu'on ventile les mines pour éviter
les mineurs de faire boom
puis en plus vous avez la combustion de la biomasse
alors pourquoi la combustion de la biomasse émet-elle
méthane
parce que le méthane est un élément volatil
qui se forme lorsque le bois
prend feu et une partie de ce méthane
n'est pas brûlé au moment de la
la combustion
et ainsi il s'échappe dans l'atmosphère
dessus tu as
bétail c'est le troupeau de bovins et
en gros les ruminants d'accord
et là-dedans vous avez essentiellement des vaches donc
Nous avons
un milliard et demi à deux milliards de vaches
sur terre donc les vaches représentent le premier
biomasse
d'animal désolé la première biomasse de
des mammifères pas des animaux c'est le premier
biomal
biomasse de mammifères sur terre en plein
devant les humains et les vaches
rotent du méthane ils ont pété
très peu je précise alors pourquoi est-ce que
ils rotent du méthane parce que les vaches sont
supérieur à vous et à moi et ils ont
quatre estomacs au lieu d'un
et dans ces estomacs tu as un complexe
processus de fermentation anaérobie
ce qui signifie en l'absence d'oxygène de
l'air et dans cet anaérobie
processus de fermentation vous avez du méthane
qui se forme et le méthane
sorties des voies respiratoires supérieures et euh
qui
contribue aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc ici vous avez
en fait les rizières c'est un processus je
parlé plus tôt c'est la décomposition
loin de l'oxygène de l'air
et ici vous avez des décharges qui
traduit aussi en français
oui alors pourquoi avons-nous des émissions de méthane
des décharges
même motif mêmes châtiments car dans
décharges que vous avez en particulier organique
déchets
bien vos épluchures de pommes de terre pour celles de
toi qui épluche les pommes de terre et alors quand ça
arrive
dans un puits dans une décharge euh
les déchets s'entassent les uns sur les autres
et certains de ses déchets
va fermenter loin de l'oxygène du
l'air et donc
émettent donc aujourd'hui du méthane dans la plupart des décharges
dans les pays occidentaux ce méthane est
capturé
mais ce n'est pas le cas partout dans le
monde
un autre gaz à effet de serre dont je vous ai parlé
c'est du protoxyde d'azote donc du protoxyde d'azote même
si ce camembert est un peu ancien, il l'est
toujours valable en um
dans ses causes et dans ses ordres de
ordre de grandeur
vous avez euh ici de l'azote
l'oxyde nitreux qui provient du
la combustion
processus afin que vous sachiez que la combustion est un
processus dans lequel
vous oxydez quelque chose avec de l'oxygène
l'air
mais en général l'oxygène de l'air
vous ne l'apportez pas pur là où il
brûlures
vous l'apportez avec l'azote du
l'air et donc le processus de combustion
va réorganiser l'azote et l'oxygène
sous forme d'oxyde d'azote donc l'azote
oxydes
de la pollution automobile que vous pourriez
bien entendre c'est
simplement l'azote qui est entré dans le
moteur
qui a fini dans le moteur
chambre de combustion qui se recombinait avec
l'oxygène et qui a émergé sous forme de
l'oxyde d'azote et certains d'entre eux
oxydes d'azote
est l'oxyde nitreux une petite partie c'est le
même chose dans l'industrie et c'est la
même chose en euh
dans les chaudières des bâtiments
donc tu as une cause essentielle
qui est euh qui est l'agriculture
alors pourquoi avez-vous du protoxyde d'azote
émissions dans l'agriculture
parce que l'agriculture utilise des engrais et
les engrais contiennent
molécules d'azote c'est l'un des
les apports d'engrais
molécules d'azote
puis ces molécules d'azote lorsque vous
étalez-les sur le sol
et qui fonctionne avec du synthétique
engrais mais aussi avec
pigmenter ou puits de fumier de vache
il y a une petite partie des molécules
qui formera
protoxyde d'azote sous l'effet du
action microbienne des sols
il s'agit donc d'émissions du sol liées à
l'application de
engrais azotés
alors vous avez des molécules appelées
halocarbures
donc comme je vous l'ai dit plus tôt ce sont
molécules que nous avons fabriquées en remplaçant dans
les hydrocarbures l'hydrogène
par les halogènes, alors pourquoi avons-nous pris la peine de faire
ceci tout simplement
parce que la liaison carbone-halogène
est une liaison extrêmement stable
ce qui signifie que lorsque vous faites ce genre
de composés surtout lorsqu'ils sont
saturé
vous fabriquez des molécules presque
indestructible
et donc non toxiques ce sont
molécules qui ont remplacé d'autres usages
en raison de leur physique intéressant
propriétés où auparavant nous utilisions des gaz
potentiellement toxiques ou
agressif
donc dans les chaines du froid il a remplacé le co2
que nous avons utilisé à un moment qui était un
peu moins bon en termes de
thermodynamique
et surtout l'ammoniac je ne sais pas si
certains d'entre vous ont déjà
s'est amusé à inhaler une grosse bouffée d'ammoniac
mais
c'est pas top donc on préfère mettre
dans les circuits frigorifiques molécules de
gaz halogénés
parce que si tu prends une grande respiration
en gros rien ne t'arrive c'est
totalement inerte
il en va de même pour les propulseurs d'aérosol
canettes
ces gaz ont été utilisés à la place des
hydrocarbures que nous utilisions auparavant
avec quels enfants à l'époque où j'étais
un enfant riait
tout en fabriquant un gros lance-flammes avec
le truc c'était fondamentalement un gros
chalumeau comme ça
Et depuis que quelques gosses se sont fait exploser la gueule
avec lui nous l'avons remplacé par quelque chose
qui n'a pas brûlé
il a également servi de gaz expanseur de mousse afin
si vous avez un vieux frigo
des années 50 traînant dans votre cave
la mousse isolante
du frigo a été fait avec un gaz comme
celui-ci qui servait de
gaz d'expansion pour que votre mousse soit remplie de
hydrocarbures et si vous dérangez
mousse et l'exposer à l'air il va
dans l'atmosphère et cela augmente la
Effet de serre
et enfin il sert aussi de solvant
dans l'industrie des semi-conducteurs
donc le plus dangereux
de ces halocarbures pour la couche d'ozone
qui s'appelait le cfc est depuis devenu
éradiqué
le cfc était une molécule très stable comme tous
les autres chlorofluorocarbures
donc seulement du fluorure de chlore et du carbone mais
comme il était très stable, il a eu le temps de
monter dans la haute atmosphère sans
être chimiquement attaqué par quoi que ce soit
dans la haute atmosphère c'est
dissocié par les rayons ultraviolets durs
puis le chlore dégagé par celui-ci
réaction
attaque l'ozone stratosphérique
alors nous avons arrêté la production, nous n'avons pas arrêté
émissions parce que vous avez des cfc qui
ont été utilisés précisément comme mousse expansive
gaz et donc
ils sont encore dans de vieux réfrigérateurs qui sont
a continué à être démantelé aujourd'hui
et donc nous ne l'avons pas complètement arrêté
et puis vous avez un certain nombre de
pays qui ont secrètement continué
faire quelques
nous les avons donc remplacés par des gaz qui
ont à peu près la même thermodynamique
propriétés dans la chaîne du froid
mais qui ne sont pas nocifs pour l'ozone
couche
par contre ils sont extrêmement
puissants gaz à effet de serre
là donc vous avez encore des gaz de ça
la nature
mais les émissions d'aujourd'hui sont encore beaucoup
plus petits qu'ils ne l'étaient dans les années 50
alors vous avez un autre gaz à effet de serre
dont j'ai parlé
qu'il n'a pas d'émission directe qui est
ozone donc ozone je le répète se trouve
à deux endroits vous l'avez dans la partie supérieure
Ambiance et celle-ci nous intéresse
énormément
il nous intéresse pour deux raisons
intercepte les rayons ultraviolets durs
du soleil
donc c'est une première chose qui intéresse
nous parce que sinon le
les rayons ultraviolets durs interféreraient
avec la vie telle que nous la connaissons sur terre
et a un deuxième effet qui est beaucoup
moins connu qui est
qu'en absorbant l'énergie dans la partie supérieure
atmosphère
il réchauffe donc la haute atmosphère
et crée
ce qu'on appelle une inversion de température
ce qui signifie que la température qui
par un effet thermodynamique de base
diminue lorsque la pression diminue donc
quand tu montes
jusqu'à l'atout opposé disons simplement
jusqu'aux limites
de la stratosphère et commence alors à
réchauffer quand nous entrons dans la stratosphère
donc cette inversion de température a
quelque chose d'absolument fondamental
c'est qu'il limite la convection
de vapeur d'eau à la limite de la
trépiposer
si cette inversion de température n'avait pas
se produire
la vapeur d'eau ne s'arrêterait pas à 15
kilomètres au-dessus du sol
il continuerait à aller plus haut, ce qui
être un peu gênant pour les précipitations
et en plus la vapeur d'eau serait
également être exposé aux ultraviolets durs
Rayons du soleil
qui se serait dissocié depuis longtemps
eau dans
l'oxygène qui serait resté allumé
de la terre et de l'hydrogène qui seraient partis
dans l'espace parce que la molécule est trop
volatil
donc l'eau qui est arrivée sur terre si
la couche d'ozone n'avait pas créé ce
inversion de température cela aurait
a disparu et
donc c'est aussi quelque chose d'absolument
crucial pour le maintien de la vie sur terre
donc cet ozone stratosphérique est formé par
l'interaction de
oxygène atmosphérique avec rayons ultraviolets
il a son propre cycle et il ne le fait pas
sortir de la stratosphère
et encore nous l'aimons beaucoup à cause de
les deux effets que je viens de mentionner
plus près du sol vous avez
ozone troposphérique ozone qui apparaît
près du sol
celui-ci nous intéresse beaucoup moins car
il n'apparaît pas pour les mêmes raisons
du tout
celui-ci apparaît parce que nous jouons un
petit chimiste en gros on met dans le
ambiance tout un cocktail donc c'est
fondamentalement top chef top chef de la pollution
et on met dans l'atmosphère de l'azote
oxydes
composés organiques volatils nous le remuons
le tout avec un peu de rayonnement solaire vous
besoin d'un peu de rayonnement solaire
et voilà l'ozone apparaît mais ça
celui qu'on aime pas du tout
parce qu'il pénètre dans nos poumons et
participe à l'effet de serre
d'accord alors celui-ci si nous pouvions l'éviter nous
préférerais que
ici vous avez des cartes qui vous montrent que
la concentration d'environ
quoi que ce soit dans les holocarbures a fortement
augmenté au cours des dernières décennies
et là vous avez des cartes qui comparent
la concentration d'ozone de fond
et vous voyez qu'il a augmenté
extrêmement fortement
ce qui signifie que même si l'ozone est un très
oxydant agressif
ce qui signifie que c'est la durée de vie et le
l'ambiance est courte car dès que
il se forme il trouve de quoi manger
et se figea dessus
alors que nous continuons à le produire
continuellement vous avez un fond d'ozone
concentration
qui est en permanence au-dessus de nos têtes plus
ou moins élevé mais en permanence
notez également que l'ozone est un inhibiteur de croissance
pour plantes
donc dans les endroits où l'ozone
la concentration est un peu élevée
et comme il faut du temps pour que l'ozone
formulaire
en région parisienne par exemple c'est
pas où
le trafic routier est que vous avez le
concentration maximale d'ozone
en général, il a besoin de temps pour se former
maximum la concentration d'ozone est
peu
est toujours un peu sous le vent de la ville
donc 10 20 30 kilomètres c'est jamais
en plein paris
c'est donc un inhibiteur de la
la croissance des plantes donc une fois que vous avez
une comparaison
de gaz les uns avec les autres, nous pouvons
oui
parce que c'est un inhibiteur de croissance des plantes
je veux dire que c'est simplement un effet observé
tu sais mais y
est toujours un comment du temps avant donc dans
fait il inhibe
je ne sais pas exactement quelle réaction dans
la photosynthèse et
là c'est juste un inhibiteur de croissance
une fois que vous avez un élément de comparaison
des gaz entre eux, nous allons
pouvoir commencer à représenter la serre
gaz ou émissions très fluviales
sous forme de camemberts donc camemberts
il y en a beaucoup que vous pouvez représenter par
gaz
vous pouvez représenter par une source que vous pouvez
représenter par pays tous les joints tous
gaz combinés, etc.
donc je vais vous offrir un certain nombre de tarte
graphiques et je vais paradoxalement
pas commencer par le graphique circulaire dans lequel
le là
sont les gaz comparés les uns aux autres
puisque euh tu verras ça plus tard
Je vais plutôt commencer par un graphique à secteurs dans
qui
j'ai attribué le gaz à effet de serre
émissions tous gaz confondus donc
co2 méthane etc.
à un certain nombre de secteurs d'activité tous
droit
donc la totalité des secteurs est 100 de
ce que nous faisons
et je décompose cela d'une manière que je
j'espère avoir un sens
le méthane émis par les mines de charbon étant
inclus
donc c'est vraiment une vue globale
centrales électriques au charbon
représente actuellement 20 % du
émissions mondiales
donc dit sinon une tonne de co2
équivalent sur cinq est um
tant pis puisque tous les gaz sont comparés à
co2 dans le potentiel de réchauffement global
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que tous les autres gaz
sont comptabilisés en équivalent co2
oui le potentiel de réchauffement global est
pris à 100 ans
cela signifie qu'une tonne d'équivalent co2
sur cinq émis dans le monde provient
un
centrale électrique au charbon ou son approvisionnement
enchaîner un sur cinq
alors vous avez des centrales électriques au gaz et au pétrole
alors c'est
principalement du gaz qui représente environ
sept pour cent des émissions mondiales en
qui est inclus
les émissions du méthane produit dans
la chaîne d'approvisionnement en gaz en amont
ajouter également les combustibles utilisés par le ciment
des usines
la production de ciment est de six pour cent
des émissions planétaires rappelez-vous
que euh les émissions françaises sont d'un point
cinq pour cent si vous voulez avoir un
ligne de base
pour tout ce que je te dis
devrait euh
donner une petite idée
le reste de l'industrie est de 12
donc dedans on comptabilise les émissions directes
je n'ai pas compté les émissions de
la production d'électricité
utilisé par l'industrie si nous
ajouter la production d'électricité utilisée par
L'industrie
la part de l'industrie va de um
bien
désolé si vous incluez les cimenteries
de
18 à quelque chose entre 25 et 30
pour cent
parce qu'une bonne part de l'électricité
passe évidemment par l'industrie
processus donc là vous avez 12
dans laquelle les aciéries représentent environ
quatre pour cent
sachant qu'environ la moitié de l'acier
produit dans le monde
est utilisé pour construire des bâtiments et
infrastructures comme les ponts et
etc et que tout le ciment
est utilisé pour faire cela, ce qui signifie essentiellement
que la construction de bâtiments et de ponts
sur terre est un petit
10 des émissions planétaires
d'accord donc ici vous trouvez aussi un
élément de croissance démographique
s'il y a plus de monde plus de bâtiments
sont construits
le chauffage des bâtiments représente six
pour cent des émissions donc je vous entends
dire ce que seulement six pour cent bien
plus tôt dans le graphique de la france on a vu
ça et cetera
oui seulement six pour cent des émissions pourquoi
car
une bonne partie des bâtiments du
le monde n'a pas besoin d'être chauffé
si vous avez un immeuble dans le sud
californie son problème n'est pas vraiment de
être chauffé si vous avez un bâtiment dans
singapour son problème n'est pas vraiment de
lagos son probleme n'est pas vraiment d'etre
chauffé
son problème cependant est peut-être d'être
climatisé et dans ce cas le
les émissions de la climatisation sont
pas là parce que ce n'est pas un radiateur
et que vous les trouverez là-bas et
puisqu'il s'agit d'émissions de
production électrique
mais en chauffage direct une bonne partie de
les bâtiments du monde n'en ont pas besoin
là tu euh je veux dire en france
vous n'avez pas cela très important
chaise parce que
nous avons très peu de centrales électriques au charbon
et le partage
ici c'est plus petit parce qu'on a fini
la construction de notre infrastructure et nous sommes
construisant un rythme moins frénétique que le
pays à forte croissance démographique
donc la part des cimenteries est
plus bas et ainsi de suite et par un effet de
tarte plus petite
tranches de graphique en nombre d'endroits
les autres tranches sont proportionnellement plus grandes
mais c'est juste pour montrer que les partages
peut varier beaucoup selon le pays
alors cette très grosse tranche rose est
le transport
donc dans les transports, le parc automobile mondial est
environ six pour cent
la flotte mondiale de camions est d'environ quatre
pour cent
euh donc quand je dis six pour cent ça peut
être sept pour cent mais c'est de cet ordre
d'ampleur
la flotte mondiale de bateaux est d'environ deux
pour cent et la flotte mondiale d'avions est
aussi environ deux pour cent
sans compter les gaz autres que le co2, mais je ne le fais pas
prendre le temps d'en parler pendant
cette leçon alors rappelez-vous deux pour cent
donc ce que vous voyez à ce stade est que
par exemple dans les utilisations de
type de machine bien la flotte mondiale de
les cimenteries est le même problème que
flotte mondiale de voitures
donc on ne parle pas de quelque chose
c'est complètement anecdotique
le parc mondial d'aciéries est le
identique à la flotte mondiale de camions
vous pouvez également voir que les centrales au charbon sont
plus important
que tous les moyens de transport du
monde si nous regardons les émissions
là donc vous commencez à avoir une ligne de base
ça te dit
si je veux régler le problème
où commencer
et vous voyez qu'il n'y a pas que nous
va éliminer les voitures et s'arrêter là
car le problème est plus compliqué
que ça
20 de nos émissions proviennent de l'alimentation
ce sont donc essentiellement des gaz sans co2
vous trouvez dans leur
les vaches le reste du troupeau restant
mais qui sont des rizières moins importantes
et les oxydes d'azote
des champs et aussi du co2 des
tracteurs mais qui est tout à fait mineur
contribution
alors vous avez la déforestation
la déforestation comme je l'ai dit plus tôt est un
en amont
processus de l'activité agricole
ce qui signifie que
manger au sens large c'est plutôt 30
des émissions planétaires
et enfin on trouve ici divers
sources
y compris par exemple la gestion des déchets
ou par exemple
fuites de la chaîne du froid, etc. tout un tas de
différentes sources
alors voici une façon de présenter
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
je vous les ai présentés ici en gros
ensembles de
émissions directes
donc en france c'est a quoi ca ressemble
tu vois qu'on retrouve les mêmes tranches dans
le camembert mais non représenté dans le
de la même façon
donc vous trouvez que le transport vient en premier
puis bâtiments en agriculture ou ou
réellement
les bâtiments sont l'agriculture et l'industrie
à peu près tous égaux
et enfin le secteur de l'énergie qui est
petit parce qu'à nouveau cuit à froid
production d'électricité que nous avons
très peu et c'est ce qui fait le plus
de la différence
il y a une autre façon de présenter
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui sont
les émissions qui résultent de notre
empreinte carbone
quelle est donc notre empreinte carbone
par opposition aux émissions qui sont dites
être territorial
c'est-à-dire les émissions qui sont faites dans
La France
ce sont des émissions qui correspondent à
ce que nous consommons
quand on regarde les émissions présentées comme
ce sont les émissions qui prennent
place
sur le sol français mais
les vêtements que vous portez par exemple là-bas
étaient beaucoup d'entre eux qui ont été
envoyé par la poste ailleurs donc par exemple
si vous portez
comme je l'ai mentionné dans le premier cours
fibres synthétiques
pour ces fibres synthétiques une partie de
leurs émissions viennent d'ailleurs
il fallait donc extraire le pétrole
les molécules ont dû être craquées
le plastique devait être fabriqué puis transformé
et les monomères polymérisés et cetera
tout un tas de choses en partie
n'a pas été fabriqué en france
alors oui pour les fibres poly quelque chose
les émissions n'ont pas été faites en france
si vous achetez un ordinateur aujourd'hui
l'ordinateur n'a pas été produit
en france donc les émissions de production
de cet ordinateur sont essentiellement supplémentaires
émissions territoriales
si vous achetez des tomates espagnoles au
saison qui est très mauvaise car elle
pompe les nappes phréatiques mais peu importe
puis vous avez acheté des tomates qui ont généré
les émissions par exemple
pour faire fonctionner des pompes ou par exemple pour
enrichir les serres en co2 car ça tourne
dehors qu'il y a
serres enrichies en co2
pour que les tomates poussent plus vite
nous brûlons donc du gaz pour enrichir les serres
co2 tout cela n'a pas
nécessairement avoir lieu en france et donc
et ainsi de suite, puis si vous achetez un
auto
qu'un fabricant même français
a fabriqué en roumanie ou au maroc
les émissions correspondantes n'ont pas non plus
avoir lieu en france
donc dans la vision du territorial
émissions
tu ne regardes que ce qui est fabriqué en france
mais cela ne correspond pas forcément à
ce que vous allez acheter ou consommer
cela ne correspond pas forcément à
qu'il correspond à ce qui se passe dans
notre pays
et corrélativement une partie des émissions
qui se produisent dans notre pays sont au
service
de quelque chose qui sera consommé
à l'étranger, par exemple lorsque vous construisez
un airbus en france la production
les émissions de l'airbus
sont normalement dans un point de consommation de
vue qu'ils sont à la charge du
Compagnie aérienne
je vais acheter l'airbus de toi qui est
pas nécessairement une entreprise française et
en fait essentiellement pas un français
compagnie
et quand tu fais du vin qui n'est pas très
très intensif en 2-2 mais
de toute façon je veux dire que vous devez faire une bouteille
le transporter dans un camion
vous devez bien faire fonctionner les tracteurs, etc.
cette bouteille de vin si elle est exportée
ce sont des missions
avoir lieu en france mais vous n'êtes pas le
celui qui prendra plaisir à boire la bouteille
donc les émissions territoriales sont les
les émissions qui se produisent en france
dans une perspective de consommation nous utilisons
ce qu'on appelle l'empreinte carbone
que vous voyez ici et qui
[Musique]
correspond aux émissions qui ont eu lieu
afin que vous puissiez profiter de la
produit ou service
vous utilisez bien
les émissions domestiques d'un français si
tu
reprends la courbe que je t'ai montré
plus tôt
donc si je reprends cette courbe et que je
diviser par la population
nous obtenons le nombre d'un peu moins de six
tonnes de co2 par français par an
juste pour le co2 si on ajoute les gaz non-co2
c'est plutôt
huit
donc ces six tonnes correspondent au domestique
émissions
là sur la vision que je donne du
empreinte carbone par français
on voit que le total est plutôt dix
montrer quelque chose
onze donc on voit qu'on est au dessus du
huit tonnes mentionnées plus haut
la différence c'est quoi
les émissions qui ont eu lieu à l'extérieur
le pays et qui
correspondent aux biens de consommation que nous
ont importés pour les consommer
dans notre pays
donc en ce qui concerne la vertu climatique de
La France
il y a évidemment une question qui se pose
c'est peut-il être apprécié en termes de
émissions territoriales donc on dit
dans notre pays nous n'admettons pas grand chose ou
est-il apprécié en ce qui concerne
émissions de notre consommation
et à ce stade, nous devrions être en mesure de
dire ce que nous consommons dans notre pays c'est
une correspondance d'émission
c'est un peu différent oui
donc les émissions domestiques de la chine ont
deviennent descellés à un peu plus haut que
celui de France
d'autre part comme vous le savez si vous
lire les récents accrochages entre les
chinois et mr trump
une partie des missions chinoises sont utilisées
à exploiter
donc en termes de vision de la consommation
les chinois sont en dessous
nous en vision territoriale ils sont maintenant
légèrement au-dessus du français
toujours en dessous des européens mais pas
dans cette grande vision tu prends le
les émissions domestiques et vous enlevez ce
est exporté et vous ajoutez ce qui est importé
fondamentalement
donc on passe de six ou huit à dix et
Ce que tu vois
sur la décomposition de ce graphe en
la fin est euh
où ou à quels actes de la vie quotidienne
sont les émissions que nous avons aujourd'hui
associé à et à la fin il demande
la question de
le citoyen consommateur électeur où est-il
va falloir faire
efforts seuls ou en association avec le
les personnes qui lui ont fourni des produits
Et services
pour réduire les émissions
d'accord c'est la question donc pour
émissions en france
une première partie vient du fait que nous
construisent des logements
donc vous savez que chaque année nous construisons
logements que nous construisons quelques centaines de milliers
donc évidemment pas tout le monde construit
lui-même une maison chaque année
peut-être que cela fonctionnerait pour quelques pétroles
émirs mais pas pour le français ordinaire
ça ne marche pas comme ça
par contre chaque année en france
tu as un 200
000 logements qui sont construits et si je dis
par rapport à un français
je regarde ce que ça représente dans
émissions
cela représente en gros quelques centaines
kilo de co2
par français par an c'est-à-dire
environ la construction de 1 à 1,5
mètres carrés par français et par an
d'accord
les émissions de la construction de logements sont peu nombreuses
cent kilos de co2 par mètre carré
tout va bien selon ce que vous faites dans
logement individuel et collectif
logement etc.
disons qu'il fluctue entre 200
et 400 donc vous voyez que lorsque vous construisez un
maison ou un appartement de 100
mètres carrés bien c'est en une seule fois
20 à 40 tonnes de co2 en allant d'un coup
à l'ambiance
alors d'où viennent ces 20 à 40 tonnes de co2
viens de
de l'acier qu'il faut fabriquer pour fabriquer
les barres d'armature du ciment
qu'il faut faire pour
faire du béton à partir de plastique qui sera
utilisé dans tout le bâtiment
les encadrements de fenêtres les bâches
que vous mettez sur le sol imperméabilisant
d'une maison ou d'un appartement avec vue je veux dire
le plastique est partout dans
bâtiments
et de tuiles et de briques je veux dire
etc
donc par français en un an 1,5 carré
mètre
par ordre de grandeur
[Musique]
alors vous avez un deuxième élément qui est
confort thermique
et le confort énergétique du logement
conférer ce que je vous ai dit dans le premier
classer
même si on dit que la france c'est tout
pays nucléaire
nous consommons quatre fois plus d'énergie dans les fossiles
formulaire
pour le chauffage des bâtiments qu'électrique
énergie
quatre fois plus
une grande partie de cela, je veux dire de la serre
les émissions de gaz et dans ce cas c'est
principalement co2
que l'on retrouve dans le logement provient
chauffage
qui est principalement fabriqué à partir de gaz et de carburant
pétrole
donc voici la partie excluant
chauffage qui est
ici en effet purement électrique donc en france
nous avons une très faible émission d'électricité
facteur
même en tenant compte des importations car
parfois nous importons de l'électricité
si nous étions en pologne ce petit morceau
ici
quelle taille serait-il
par rapport à celui-là je veux dire serait-il
double avec le quadruple avec un textuel
avec un tenopl
donc fondamentalement vous ce serait du poulpe et
je ne suis même pas sûr que cela existe
mais il serait multiplié par huit pour
dix.
donc cette barre ici serait supérieure à
ce bar là
c'est donc une des caractéristiques de
la france qui comme vous le savez est bas carbone
électricité
si tu vas en suisse en suède
norvège tu trouveras
une proportion ou plus exactement une
importance
de la consommation d'électricité domestique en
l'empreinte carbone totale qui est également
va être raisonnablement faible
par contre si vous allez dans des pays
qui ont une électricité élevée
carbone
et donc dans les pays où en
en plus du chauffage il y a de l'air
conditionnement
généralement dans un climat continental
le milieu des etats unis
nous mourons de froid en hiver et nous mourons
de la chaleur en été et voilà
et en plus leurs maisons sont mal
isolé là vous aurez les deux
important
émissions de chauffage et très élevé
consommation électrique consommation
émissions
potentiellement alors on retrouve cette barre ici
qui s'appelle miam miam alors ce que tu peux
voir c'est que
sur ce graphique et il y a des analogies
qui donnent ce consommateur légèrement inférieur
marchandises mais
ce sont les deux principales sources d'émission
qui se démarquent
à peu près ce qui viendra en premier dans le
l'empreinte carbone
d'un français c'est le gaz à effet de serre
émissions qui sont la contrepartie de
ce que vous achetez
dans les biens courants et durables
et ceux-ci incluent également des achats comme
machines à laver voitures etc et
la nourriture donc la nourriture
et le shopping représentent environ la moitié du carbone
empreinte d'un français
donc à chaque fois que tu vas aux ventes bam
le compteur de co2 monte
je veux dire à chaque fois que tu vas acheter des vêtements
ou canapé
ou ou dès que vous entrez dans un
supermarché et sortir avec quelque chose
qui ne se mange pas comme une brosse à dents ou
brosse de toilette ou tout ce que vous voulez
le co2 a augmenté parce que nous avons dû
faire un de ces euh
cent mille produits depuis
sur le nombre de choses que vous trouvez
au supermarché de nos jours
et donc comme je vous l'ai expliqué dans le
première leçon
la chaîne a commencé à partir de la
l'extraction des matières premières vers
dernière livraison au supermarché
pour que ce produit ou service existe afin
en euh
dans la nourriture et dans les achats je mets le
le plus grand
composant contributif dans chaque colonne
et donc la menace
n'a pas été attribué au produit car
au moment où nous avons fait cette analyse en
carbone 4
nous n'avons pas été en mesure d'allouer le fret par
catégorie de marchandise
donc on pourrait dire qu'on aurait pu faire
une estimation qui est um
une distribution au prorata sauf
qu'en réalité
le fret est à parata de tonnages et
tonnages
n'est pas nécessairement bon pour la valeur, donc un
camion qui transporte des ordinateurs n'est pas le
même valeur qu'un camion transportant
salades je veux dire en ce qui concerne le contenu de
la cargaison
donc nous avons lutté et nous n'avons pas imputé sur
d'autre part ce que vous voyez ici
est que le plus grand contributeur de nourriture
est de la viande et en particulier de la viande rouge et
si j'ajoute les produits laitiers qui sont
un autre dérivé du troupeau bovin
puis la part des émissions qui entrent dans
france de l'existence d'un bovin
troupeau
représente entre la moitié et les deux tiers de notre
empreinte carbone
oui bien sûr
en fait c'est une analyse du cycle de vie donc
ce que nous allons compter dans le
émissions de viande
sont les émissions agricoles qui ont été
utilisé pour faire pousser les plantes qui se nourriront
l'animal
donc tu as l'essence du tracteur
vous avez le fabricant d'azote
engrais qui seront utilisés sur le
les récoltes de plantes
et cela est fait en craquant le méthane de sorte
je veux dire des engrais azotés c'est
chimie de l'ammoniac
et la chimie de l'ammoniac qui commence par
produire de l'hydrogène par craquage du méthane
et ça fait autant de tubes que tu veux
oui je vais juste finir de répondre
cette question et ensuite je vous rejoindrai
vous aurez donc les émissions de n2o
des champs
vous l'aurez aussi puisque c'était
nécessaire que ces émissions prennent
endroit pour avoir les plantes
puis vous avez les émissions d'un
métabolisme de la vache
d'accord, je veux dire ouais et tout ce qui met
bout à bout et en fait tout ça met
ensemble
qui fait l'empreinte carbone de la viande
dans la colonne que vous voyez juste là
c'est pareil avec les fromages sauf que
il y a une question d'attribution qui est
dire que le troupeau de bétail produit
viande lait et fromage c'est-à-dire
lait transformé et la question est
comment allons-nous répartir cela afin que nous puissions
en discuter pendant des heures
comment le répartissons-nous économiquement
ou basé sur la masse
sachant qu'une vache laitière fait 10 tonnes
de lait par an pendant quelques années
et puis au final tu as 500 kilos
de carcasse reste
donc est fait de déchets auquel cas c'est
vaut zéro
ou il rencontre le truc qui coûte cher
et donc ça ne vaut pas zéro du tout
et donc il y a un tas de
possibilités et c'est donc l'idée dans
le schéma que je vous montre
nous comptons tout ce qui était nécessaire
du début à la fin
alors oui, il y a une question ici dans le
retour
attention ne pas confondre deux choses
ici ce que je compte n'est pas le co2 de
le carbone contenu dans les végétaux
ce sont les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sans le carbone contenu dans le
végétaux
qui sont nécessaires pour que les plantes
poussez donc pour que les plantes poussent, vous avez un
tracteur qui passe et qui brûle
diesel
ou du gaz qui n'est pas le carbone dans le
plantes vous épandez de l'engrais dans
champ c'est
n2o ce n'est pas le carbone des plantes
et je ne compterai pas une seconde
le temps car la vache quand elle rumine
cela n'équivaut pas à passer un
tracteur pour un champ et c'est
n'équivaut pas non plus à répandre
des engrais au sol et donc c'est un
toute la chaîne
et il y avait une question dans le dos
oui c'est ce que j'ai dit plus tôt c'est un
question d'attribution donc
essentiellement pour faire un kilo de fromage conte
qui est excellent bien sur je recommande
ce
vous avez besoin de 10 litres de lait donc le
concours contenu carbone par kilo est
environ 10 fois la teneur en carbone de
par kilo de lait
et ce que je vous ai montré était lié à un
unité de masse j'aurais pu en prendre une autre
unité
j'aurais pu le relier à une calorie je
aurait pu le relier à un euro de toute façon
il y a toujours une convention dans l'histoire
même là je te réfère au kilo
la calorie est probablement plus pertinente si vous
veux commencer à faire des comparaisons
entre les aliments
donc juste pour finir une dernière fois le fait
que tu as tellement
pour le lait et tant pis pour la viande je répète
à un moment donné
c'est une convention si on regarde
races laitières
nous utilisons principalement des races laitières pour produire
Le Lait
donc on peut dire qu'à peu près la carcasse
d'une vache en fin de vie
est un gaspillage, ce qui signifie que vous feriez du lait
même si personne n'a acheté la carcasse
donc dans une analyse du cycle de vie lorsque vous
avoir un déchet
que vous appréciez qui compte pour zéro et
si vous dites qu'il a encore un peu
valeur que vous pouvez compter pour la parata
de la masse
mais encore une fois puisque vous avez 30 tonnes de
lait produit par la vache
sur sa durée de vie
ce qui fait 500 kilos de carcasse au final
tu vois ça
il n'attribue pas beaucoup d'émissions à
viande si vous
regrouper les vaches laitières au
fin de vie et les races à viande
qui sont utilisés pour la viande alors vous avez un
valeur moyenne de la teneur en carbone par kilo
de viande qui est beaucoup plus élevé
donc ça dépend vraiment de la façon dont les maths sont
fait cependant
ici ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a fait
pas discriminer c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris
les émissions de l'ensemble du cheptel bovin
et on dit que ça compte dans la viande
oui
donc le nucléaire nous avons un chapitre là-dessus donc
je t'en parlerai alors
voici ce que j'essaie juste de dire obtenir
vous pensez est
les émissions et moi en d'autres termes là-dedans
que peut décider le consommateur je veux dire
sans en parler longuement aujourd'hui
mais ça prépare cette discussion
que peut décider le consommateur qui est de
dire ce qui est dans mon libre arbitre
et que puis-je décider de faire ou de ne pas faire
et ce qui est un peu plus compliqué
parce qu'il est lié à la façon dont la société est
organisés dans un contexte où nous allons
demande modérément mon avis
donc ce que vous voyez à la fin, c'est que la nourriture
arrive en première position
et il est important de le souligner
car depuis très très longtemps et
encore aujourd'hui
la question de la lutte contre
le changement climatique est souvent présenté comme un
problème
avant tout non-climat c'est-à-dire vent
turbines et panneaux solaires
et quand nous entrons dans des climats de
le transport sur lequel nous allons beaucoup nous concentrer
le transport
alors que je vous montre ici que les deux premiers
secteurs vus du
consommateur final ne sont pas ceux-là et donc dans
cette colonne vous avez ce que vous achetez
biens de consommation
quiz pop quelle était la hauteur de cette colonne dans
bien en 1990 la colonne
était la hauteur de cela plus les cuves
c'est-à-dire ce qui s'est passé
entre 1990 et 2010
est que les émissions qui sont les
les comptes font partie de ce que nous avons acheté avant
électronique
sens chemises tables canapés classes etc
est resté plus ou moins le même et
nous avons ajouté à cela les émissions de
fabrication électronique
et la fabrication électronique
les émissions, donc je n'ai pas préparé de diapositive sur
mais je vais
essayez de le laisser dans le diaporama que je
laisser en testament
euh alors rappelez-vous qu'aujourd'hui les émissions
de um du système numérique mondial
c'est-à-dire la production annuelle de
ordinateurs de
toutes sortes peut-être des serveurs ou des ordinateurs
comme celui que j'utilise
vos smartphones qui sont en fait
des ordinateurs déjà beaucoup plus puissants
que le premier ordinateur que j'ai mentionné
plus tôt
qui a été fabriqué dans les années 1950
et les éléments de réseau qui sont
nécessaire pour qu'il communique
et les centres de données et l'électricité
ce qui est nécessaire
chaque année pour fournir tout cela où pour
à la fois la production annuelle de tous ces
composants et l'électricité qui
alimente tout chaque année
bien toutes les émissions correspondant
à tout cela chaque année est déjà quatre
% des émissions planétaires
qui est de sauver le même que le global
flotte de camions et elle augmente de 10
chaque année plus ou moins
si vous cherchez quelque chose
non durable
le numérique est aujourd'hui le plus emblématique
chose que nous faisons qui est
non durable l'idée que nous avons
dématérialisé en mettant le numérique
partout malheureusement c'est l'exact
en face que nous faisons là donc
ce compartiment n'existait pas il y a 20 ans
depuis
et croyez-le ou non, je suis né dans un
monde
où il n'y avait pas de smartphones
un tel monde a existé
ça a existé
il n'y avait pas d'ordinateurs portables donc là
et même les téléphones portables n'existaient pas
ici vous avez la partie correspondant à
individuel
voyages donc dans leurs déplacements professionnels sont
pas pris en compte par exemple si
vous avez un haut-parleur venant du
états-unis pour vous faire la leçon dans ce
école
en avion car il est peu probable que
il viendra en kayak de mer
bon alors ce n'est pas dans le carbone
empreinte de l'américain à portée de main
parce que c'est un voyage d'affaires alors vous voici
n'ont que des voyages personnels
ce que vous voyez c'est que l'essentiel
est en voiture
mais il y a un gros paquet qui est
essentiellement l'avion et
l'avion est le même en 1990 ce bloc
existait à peine
quand j'étais ton agent désolé d'être le
vieux bonhomme mais
je suis allé aux états-unis pour un
stage donc c'était dans
1982 bien
en 1986 pour aller jouer aux États-Unis
états devait passer la nuit à orly
aéroport
prendre une charte qu'il n'a même pas
savoir à quelle heure ça allait vraiment
Pars
et puis c'était comme l'aventure d'un
durée de vie donc vous êtes arrivé 10 heures dans
avancer et cetera et
tu l'as fait une fois et c'était comme un
réalisation remarquable et à l'époque
en encore plus
plus qu'aujourd'hui était réservé aux
partie supérieure de la classe europa
et ainsi de suite donc l'avion a explosé
au cours des 15 dernières années
et d'ailleurs ces émissions ne sont pas
compté dans tout inventaire national
parce que quand un avion d'air france part
un aéroport allemand pour aller aux unis
états avec un passager moteur
eh bien personne ne veut les émissions du
dire français
non il transportait un passager qui n'était pas
de chez moi pour aller de l'allemagne à la
États-Unis donc ça ne peut même pas être le mien
si c'est air france ça ne peut pas être miné
l'allemagne dira bien ça peut être le mien
puisqu'il allait aux états-unis
les états-unis diront que c'est impossible
le mien puisqu'il transportait un indien et
l'indien dit que ça ne peut pas être le mien parce que
je prenais un avion français
donc le résultat final est que ces choses
n'appartient à personne
et il ne figure dans aucun inventaire national
et il se trouve dans une catégorie appelée
aviation internationale
quand vous voyez dans les graphiques d'émissions
une ligne appelée aviation internationale
eh bien ce sont en fait les émissions
que personne ne veut parce que
il s'est déroulé dans l'espace international
et donc si c'est l'aviation internationale
que c'est un
avion français transportant un indien de
l'allemagne vers la grande bretagne
et s'il s'agit d'une expédition internationale, c'est
la même chose c'est un cargo ou un
porte-conteneurs de mursk un danois
entreprise qui a quitté
adverbe pour shanghai transportant des marchandises
Fabriqué en Corée
et c'est pareil tout le monde dit le
les émissions ne sont pas les miennes
oui
parce que c'est pas cher c'est ce que je
expliqué la dernière fois donc
divisé en minutes de temps de travail
le prix d'un avion a été divisé par
10 billets d'avion alors pourquoi s'embêter quand
easyjet vous propose un vol vers
Bratislava
pour 40 euros tu viens de le faire
oui la tension est imperceptible
insignifiant donc le train en france
est um est environ deux pour cent
dans des ordres de grandeur bien sûr de la
l'énergie pour le transport ainsi utilisée par
transport aérien et routier ainsi et dans
ajout
c'est à faible teneur en carbone donc ce n'est pas visible
je veux dire que c'est dans l'épaisseur de la ligne
en fait c'est moins que l'épaisseur de
la ligne
alors euh les chiffres en france pour
le transport aérien intérieur parce que nous avons
comparer des choses comparables
donc le transport aérien domestique
c'est euh c'est quelques millions de passagers
par an
donc parer pour perdre c'est disons 2.5
disons donc cinq millions de passagers
plus de mille kilomètres
dans les ordres de grandeur donc c'est cinq
millions de fois par
mille qui est cinq milliards
voyageurs-kilomètres et le train est
beaucoup plus important
de l'ordre de 70.
euh donc ce que vous voyez donc donc ce bar dans
1990 il ne montait qu'à cette hauteur
puis cette partie verte a été ajoutée et
enfin nous avons des services publics
alors pourquoi avez-vous des émissions pour le public
prestations de service
donc de très mauvaises nouvelles pour vous à chaque fois que vous
entrez dans ce théâtre vide que vous émettez
gaz à effet de serre
parce que nous devons chauffer ce bâtiment dans
l'hiver et parce que
l'école a dû être construite longtemps
il y a donc maintenant en effet diverses prescriptions
mais parce que j'ai ainsi que tous les
d'autres enseignants doivent venir à l'école
et cetera et donc l'éducation nationale
provoque des commissions et le national
l'éducation emploie près d'un million
personnes
il emploie presque un million
ça euh ça chauffe beaucoup de bâtiments donc
il y a beaucoup de
bâtiments scolaires lycées
écoles primaires etc.
qui sont chauffés et donc ceux-ci sont
émissions
et le deuxième émetteur majeur est la santé
la santé cause probablement
de l'ordre de cinq pour cent du
l'empreinte carbone du pays parce qu'il est
nécessaire de
garder les hôpitaux fabriquent des médicaments
consommables scanners
dispositifs qui sont utilisés pour savoir si
tu as attrapé une maladie honteuse ou pas
etc et donc toutes ces choses
vont contribuer à la
l'empreinte carbone de l'hôpital
et enfin le dernier gros émetteur du
service publique
auquel vous n'avez probablement pas pensé est
ah c'est bien l'armée oui donc pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont vu top gun vous
rappelez-vous que l'armée a
gros objets qui consomment beaucoup et beaucoup
de kérosène comme carburant
et la consommation de pétrole de l'armée américaine est
entre un tiers
et la moitié de la consommation de pétrole de
La France
d'accord, donc en France, je veux dire que nous avons un
petite armée
et cela représente encore quelques points et
je veux dire et
cela nous appartient à tous donc dans ton carbone
empreinte depuis
c'est aussi dire bénéficiant de la
fait que nous avons un système de soins
système éducatif
et une armée là-bas donc c'était le
changement climatique
partie sur ce qu'est le climat et euh
sont les émissions etcetera et la prochaine fois
nous verrons ce que cela fait au climat
système et quelles en sont les conséquences
alors bonne soirée a tous